yo yo yo yo alors on est de retour on va
choper on va choper les parties
je vais
je vais mettre les bons noms parce que
pour une raison
qui m'a absolument inconnue
je comprends pas ici en fait
donc on va changer ça
et on va récupérer les caméras
on va récupérer ça on va mettre les
caméras ok donc ça c'est bon ça c'est
bon
et le chrono je sais pas pourquoi il
s'est pas lancé
on va voir si leur chronos se lance
sinon on mettra le nôtre et je vais
récupérer les caméras et on est bon
le son a changé
OK
il a pris le micro de la cam ouais
possible ouais c'est le son était
dégueulasse non
j'imagine en tout cas
moi je vais récupérer les câbles et on
va suivre ce match ensemble tranquillou
sans forcer
c'est long
les speechs c'est long
faut pas faut pas démarrer trop fort
on en a pour 4 heures
j'allais me prendre une bouteille d'eau
et tout on va on va se mettre tranquille
alors pourquoi blanc noir
en fait ils veulent tourner tout le
temps on va pas faire on va pas faire ça
comme
ok une cam un peu bizarre on va enlever
le blanc noir on s'en fout en fait
on va se mettre côté gris Tchouk
il est un peu Arbi le cadre parce que
grichu qui a lui-même un cadre autour de
sa cam
OK et on va récupérer digne
et après on est bon
[Musique]
il a pas l'air bien Ding
oh il a l'air dessus
en fait le problème c'est que
ouais alors design il est pas fait pour
faire ça
j'avais pas compris un truc c'est quand
on tournait de couleur ouais bon nous on
va regarder comme ça
mais eux ils veulent toujours avoir les
blancs en bas en fait
bon tant pis
il est 22h en Chine
ouais c'est mieux comme je fais moi en
vrai mais simplement ils ont
pas les design prévus pour
en fait eux ils veulent changer de blanc
et noir à chaque fois et nous on veut
regarder le POV d'un joueur
tu commences seul ouais aujourd'hui
demain on commandera avec Baki le match
de Maxime aujourd'hui on commence seul
parce que
ouais c'est un match du premier tour il
y a pas non plus giga et pas on va pas
se mentir
donc on se regarde ça un petit peu
tranquille on se fait un peu comme un
watch party sans forcer quoi
c'est grisou quand même
mais bon
il y a quand même 15 matchs en l'espace
de 20 jours quoi 25 jours donc
tranquille
elle va se rencontrer
à 19h
là c'est un match un match tranquille du
premier tour
on va voir si si Sacha réussit à bien
jouer mais la Ding je pense qu'il est
une belle position
ça a l'air d'être chiant à jouer avec
les Noirs ça il y a beaucoup de il y a
du jeu à l'elroit avec le fou qui tape
le fou qui tape en fait qui veut venir
en C6
en tout cas c'est ça fait partie des
matchs les plus serrés et ouais c'est
une super affiche
dur de savoir qui est favori je pense
objectivement ça doit quand même être
népaulement favori mais le match 155 ans
bah ouais il y a un petit problème en
haut à gauche mais je sais pas pourquoi
donc on va voir si réussi à régler ça
je sais pas pourquoi le chronomètre
c'est pas lancé
est-ce que Ding va gagner facile
non mais je pense que Ding est favori
quand même l'an dernier il avait super
bien joué contre Naka
donc là voir il réussit à faire cavalier
4 là cette position là
elle est compliquée d'un côté il y a la
paire de fou pour les blancs mais de
l'autre côté il y a le petit avantage
structurel avec C4 et tu as un mauvais
fou aussi
tu ferais une nouvelle entrée de Maxime
pas du tout
je veux pas savoir en fait ça m'évite
d'avoir des trucs à savoir puis je m'en
fous un petit peu aussi en vrai
complètement à vrai dire c'est ouais pas
non plus tu vois j'en dors la nuit
j'y pense pas en fait je me dis pas
merde qui est l'entraîneur de Maxime je
m'en fous complètement en fait
quand Maxime Le diraille le dira mais en
gros c'est pas c'est pas mon centre
d'intérêt main
c'est ce qui est intéressant pour nous
c'est de regarder les parties ou quoi
après ils prennent les ils font ce
qu'ils veulent au niveau de leur
entourage et tout ça nous ça nous
regarde pas c'est leur c'est leur petite
tambouille à eux c'est pas trop rentrer
dans les personnel des sportifs c'est
pas forcément
tout ne doit pas forcément être sûr en
fait du public
en quelque sorte il y a des choses qu'on
a à savoir et puis les choses qu'on a
pas à savoir ben on les sait pas et puis
et puis c'est normal et puis c'est tout
quoi
il veut essayer d'empêcher la dame de
rentrer je sais pas qui est mieux
j'ai peur que ça soit les blancs quand
même
il va peut-être essayer de jouer avec
cinq après et envoyer F4 F5 je pense que
c'est vraiment mieux au blanc maintenant
ce fou aussi c'est un vrai problème il
faudrait qu'il reste le foot casse noir
pour pouvoir un peu taper sur les cases
j'espère quand même qu'il y a pas
d'embrouille avec le presse déjà il y en
a pas mais en fait quand bien même il y
en aurait de toute façon c'est leur vie
privée qu'est-ce que tu en as à [ __ ]
en vrai
faut laisser les la vie privée aux gens
c'est pas Maxime Baki ou quoi c'est pas
c'est pas tes potes en fait
donc ils ont leurs life ils font leur
choix ils font leur live c'est pas faut
pas faut pas se mêler de la vie privée
des gens parce que tu les connais
toi tu parles à quelque chose parfois
ouais je vais parler à deux trois jours
mais là il a un peu dans le dur Sacha
bref ça se sent là la position elle est
difficile les pions qui vont avancer
côté blanc
les fous qui cisaille
fort allez il essaie de ramener le
cavalier aussi quand même
ouais c'était bien joué
il réussit pour le moment à tenir
H4 h6 il va faire fouet
et ouais ouf H5 c'est peut-être faute
il a raté puis on prend il faut 7
Sacha qui reste dans le dur quand même
ça défend encore pour le moment plus que
deux secondes pour Sacha
ça tourne
allez il ouvre un petit peu le pion H6
Ding
il va faire ça je pense d'ingly Rennes
fougez trois fois H4 pour fouder 8
et encore cavalier aussi si l'attaque le
fou fou au 4 héros défend quelle défense
de Sacha
Sacha qui va tenir cette partie
OK
bon première partie traitant du on voit
Sacha qui souffle ça Sud est la première
ça remarche allez ça repart et ça va
reçu
donc c'est un demi un demi pour le
moment
allez ça va OK
il y a pas beaucoup pratiqué les échecs
et j'ouvre depuis le Grand Prix de
Ingrid Chuck le truc c'est que c'est
qu'il y a sa femme là qui qui joue et
qui est qui joue derrière en ce moment
le tournoi des candidates
la gagnante de tournoi qui jouera le
match de championnat du monde pour le
titre mondial
chez les femmes et
Sacha il a il a plusieurs enfants je
crois qu'ils ont trois ou quatre enfants
avec sa compagne et donc il s'occupe des
gamins en fait Sacha père de famille
avant tout
père de famille avant tout Sacha
donc il a pas forcément le temps de de
concilier vie de joueurs pro et perd et
paire de 4 enfants en même temps
tu es pas prenable non si tu prends en
B4 tu vas perdre tu vas perdre 5
il prépare sa femme non il prépare pas
sa femme mais
il s'occupe des enfants
ce qui n'est pas ce qui n'est pas si
simple
c'est quand même c'est quand même
beaucoup quatre enfants je suis plus un
trois ou quatre
quand bien même ce serait trois
c'est difficile de concilier vie de
joueurs pro et
père de famille comme ça
en tout cas il y a une belle position
avec les Blancs il va pouvoir jouer B5
et taper sur le centre
ça joue fort un côté gritchouk
mais il va pouvoir taper sur le centre
tu peux me l'apporter j'ai oublié de la
prendre
[Musique]
je veux l'autre
non réellement
non
terrible
je pense
pas la bouteille orange ouais c'est
tellement ça
pas facile à jouer il faudrait qu'il
réussisse à jouer avec F5 E4 Ding mais
il en est loin
en tout cas il réfléchit prend du temps
là ça va envoyer un bac sinco clairement
tranquille
je suis pas bien je suis pas bien du
tout
la semaine dernière ça fait déjà ce
dimanche jetable dimanche prochain je
tape et dans deux semaines aussi
et Elena ouais
est enceinte de 7 mois ou 7 mois et demi
là je sais plus du coup je suis un petit
peu un petit peu pas trop net mais bon
ça se comprend
donc
ton stage
je sais pas honnêtement je sais pas
je sais pas si ça va faire baisser un
coup j'ai 5
il hésite en tout cas il prend du temps
là c'est du 5 + 2 5 + 1 pardon donc il y
a le temps cadence un peu molle je
trouve
je trouve que c'est une cadence un peu
molle personnellement
c'est vrai que c'est un peu long quoi
surtout quand on voit qu'il y aura
beaucoup de points qui se jouent en
belette à la fin
c'est un peu trop long
c'est un peu trop long on va voir il
hésite c'est normal
de la belette pour départager il joue il
joue une demi-heure de belette à la fin
mais il y a autant de parties de belette
que de 5 plus 5
le meilleur ambullet est très avantagé
après il y a pas de telles écarts de
niveau en belette
tout le monde joue bien en belette
maintenant
ah ils invitent pas baquer parce qu'il
aurait oui il aurait tous les points en
bols si tu as envie de Bachy c'est ça le
problème
pourquoi 5 + 2 pour la BK alors déjà
c'est 5 + 2 de chaises Blitz
pas pour le tournage final mais pour la
phase de poules mais c'est que pour les
gens
qui sont moins forts et qui veulent
participer au tournoi puisse jouer parce
que 3 plus simple pour les amateurs ça
va un peu trop vite
c'est pour que les joueurs pour que tout
le monde puisse jouer
mais la phase finale la backup elle sera
en 3 plus 5 évidemment
et là on est sur des joueurs quand même
qui ont le niveau pour jouer en 3 + 1
il doit hésiter à faire B5 et cavalier
B4
commence par fouder 5
B6 il veut se libérer le de l'attaque du
pion pour pouvoir naviguer avec le
cheval
après une chose j'appelle Sacha parce
que son prénom en fait
parce que c'est son prénom
pas évident de savoir comment
comment continuer il y a pas les pièces
arrivent pas sur les bonnes cases les
cavaliers là sont un peu bizarres
donc sur dame prend et ce qui pourra
faire cavalier prend pour essayer de
revenir vers le cadre je sais pas si on
a le temps
s'il va avoir un problème avec un
cavalier 7 qui va lui bloquer le fou
est-ce qu'il y a eu 7 il y a encore
peut-être des fou B7 qui traînent pour
taper la tour et le pion
donc c'est pas évident mais il y a
peut-être un dame prend F3 et à 5 qui
peut être gênant
et c'est tout bloquer sur casse blanche
là-bas et avoir les mains libres pour
jouer à l'ailera après côté noir parce
que les Noirs ils ont une majorité de
d'option allait le droit
important de voir ça
donc c'est de ce côté d'échiquet avec
les Noirs veulent jouer
peut-être à 5 ici quand même au prochain
et donc les blancs doivent peut-être
l'éviter en jouant en tête B5 même
pour essayer au monde échanger le pion
et donner un peu de cola et de se garder
un peu la case B4 aussi
je pense qu'il est en train de regarder
cavalier des deux et F5 or il commence
par B5 j'aime bien ce coup prendre le
taureau par les cornes
ça permet de pas avoir un pion à 5 là
qui contrôle cette case D4 et peut-être
un jour d'avoir un rebond via B4 en
dessin
je sais pas si ça va les prendre ici
car il prend des cinq à cavaliers prend
D7 sur échec et cavalier prend le 5 fous
prend le 5 tours E5
F6 tours 2 cavaliers prend des 5 tours 8
3.8
puis on prend des 5 tours C2 ça doit
être le problème
Sacha qui essaie de calculer on voit il
veut essayer de le faire marcher
ah mais il peut peut-être sur F6 faire
tout reprendre le 7 et cavalier prend
des quatre
c'est ça l'idée sur F6 il va prendre en
fait voilà c'était calculé aussi côté
commentateur
les prises 7 prises des quatre et cette
position
elle est peut-être mieux pour les Noirs
parce qu'on a toute une agglo une
agglomération de pièces sur casse
blanche
et peut-être qu'il y a cause de ça il y
a un blocus pénible qui va se mettre en
place en tout cas tant qu'il y a le
cavalier en vie on a l'espoir de jouer
des 4 cavaliers trois fois F3 et ses 5
peut-être un jour
allez ça peut ça peut le faire encore
pour Alexander
pour des deux biens joués mais il y a
peut-être un C5 pour cavalier C4
cavaliers prend des deux c'est joué par
Sacha
oh il tombe
il a dû refuser cavaler ses quatre
reprend des 5 et prendre des doigts à
cause de pions prends des 4
et Sacha qui s'incline
ça fait un point un punto pour Ding
un peu contre le cours du jeu cette
partie
après c'était tendu tout le long c'est
Alexander qui a
qui a mis pression
made in a bien défendu et il a réussi à
la retourner au dernier moment
ça a versé le score ouais
alors attendez on pouvait pas le savoir
avant
mais maintenant on le sait
ah non c'est eux qui ont versé le score
en bas
bon je sais pas ils ont fait de la merde
merci au chat pour pour l'info mais ils
ont mis gris tchouc un ennemi aussi
bon on peut pas vraiment savoir si le
c'est dans quel sens ils vont le
remettre en tout cas le score c'est bien
un point et demi à 1/2 mais en faveur du
joueur chinois
ah ben complet avec de voir qu'il y a
une partie quand même oh bah oui c'est
pas évident
toujours
mais c'est bien digne qui a pris la tête
de ce match
ils vont bientôt s'en rendre compte à
mon avis de cette petite erreur
qui n'est pas bien grave moi je sais pas
pourquoi le chrono n'a n'est pas lancé
en tout cas on a une structure qui peut
ressembler à certaines françaises mais
on a plus les pièces qui vont avec
je vais essayer de voir
je vais essayer de demander pour le
chronomètre
au pire on va le cut
je sais pas pourquoi j'ai 4 c'est un
coup bizarre
c'est quoi les autres affiches du
speedchasse l'autre belle affiche pour
nous ce sera demain à 19h n'est pas bien
Chi
le geai
Sacha qui a pas l'air en grande forme
il a pas le clic qui part
mais bon
il va falloir continuer avec F4 c'est
pas très orthodoxe comme manière de
jouer
mais il veut contrôler les cases c'est
un peu bizarre quand même
j'aime beaucoup cavalier C8 parce qu'il
veut venir en D6 et toucher la case de 4
j'ai compris
en fait il va être tout dans un sens
j'ai compris pourquoi on avait le
mauvais score
en fait ils font pas du tout comme nous
une bonne position il tape sur D4 il y a
ce pion qui est qui est isolé et
pas envie de dire complètement faible
parce que c'est dur de l'attaquer plus
de deux fois mais les pièces blanches
sont un petit peu
bloqués à son à sa protection
et d'un autre côté il y a des cases
aussi
il y a pas mal de choses qui sont en
faveur des noirs
après c'est pas évident à jouer le
cavalier pour le moment qui tient la
case c'est 5 et B5 et E4 qui empêche aux
cavalier des 6 de venir de jaillir sur
dame B6 il y a des tours des deux
c'est le speed chasse champion de chip
donc c'est un tournoi
pour pour le vainqueur il y a 20 000
dollars et peut-être quelques primes
donc s'il y a pas énormément d'argent à
gagner mais c'est un tournant quand même
assez honorifique un peu la Rolls Royce
des tournois Internet
et pourquoi qui prend des 4
fonctionnerait pas parce que ça a ses
protégé et qui a validé 5 pareil c'est
protégé
les pions sont protégés pour le moment
on peut pas on peut pas aller les
prendre
cavalier de il se recroquevient un petit
peu je pense que Sacha va jouer dame B6
quand même pour bloquer le cavalier pas
le laisser partir et rajouter de la
pression et c'est après de faire cavaler
des cinq
on sent que
les blancs sont sont vraiment pièces et
points liés
à la défense il refait un D8
par rideau elle a dû avoir un autre plan
il doit vouloir mener la dame en H4
comment on sait si quand il reste de
temps sur la cadence bon on a du mal à
savoir justement à cause de ce
chronomètre qui fonctionne pas
et je sais pas pourquoi il fonctionne
pas c'est bien tout là le problème
il y a très peu de tournant
internationaux
de Blitz championnat du monde de Blitz
mais oui il y a peu de tournois
en Open avec avec les meilleurs joueurs
avec tous les meilleurs buteurs du monde
en fait je crois qu'il y a que le
championnat du monde de Blitz c'est que
deux jours par an
ça a démarré à 15h30
donc on sait qu'il reste encore une
heure
c'est quand la fréquence de ce tournoi
c'est une fois par an en novembre et
décembre et la fréquence champion du
monde de Blitz c'est une fois par an les
29 et 30 décembre généralement
et il joue de chez eux exactement
ah donc Sacha qui fait rien ça c'est pas
facile de de s'approcher de la position
adverse ici
Mathieu joue quel tournoi il joue le
tournoi de Kill Kenny en Irlande
ça fait une petite nulle
c'était trop de risques pour les noirs
et pour les blancs aussi de jouer le
gain
est-ce qu'on connaît l'horaire c'est
demain 19h
c'est toujours ces Espagnols
là il connaît on voit Sacha là qui qui
se
qui se met à réfléchir qui essaie de se
remémorer il envoie ses trois
c'est quoi les meilleurs ouvertures en
blitz
tout est jouable ça dépend ce que tu
connais ce que tu aimes jouer
c'est aussi simple que ça
qui a joué tes 4
sur BC il veut peut-être prendre en 5
sur baisser mais peut-être prendre 5 et
taper sur le cheval
est-ce que ça me manque de faire des
tournois non pas particulièrement je
suis pas assez fort en fait en vrai j'en
fais des tournois
par exemple les title j'en joue les
mardis de temps en temps ou quoi mais
je suis pas assez fort
j'ai pas le niveau pour pour pouvoir
lutter contre les meilleurs mondiaux
donc c'est pas c'est pas intéressant en
fait j'ai aucune chance de gagner un
gros truc
manque de niveau terrible
qui prend des cases ça va reprendre de c
ça va être un pion isolé mais j'ai
l'impression que les blancs vont avoir
une belle position avec le fou bet3 qui
tape bien sur cette diagonale et il y a
peut-être des jolis cases aussi à jouer
pour Sacha et une colonne c'est un peu
dégarni de défense de pions
bonne position
pour les blancs
j'aime bien en tout cas l'ordinateur
d'un égal mais moi j'aime bien avec les
Blancs
je trouve que ça se joue facilement
je comprends pas les gens qui ne valent
pas s'inscrire à becap avec stariments
je suis pas assez fort
parce que c'est différent en fait
c'est soit tu arrêtes de jouer
complètement comme moi parce que tu es
pas assez fort mais moi par exemple je
vais aller faire un tournoi de tennis
avec Fab
c'est pas du tout la même chose de
de faire un sport pour s'amuser ou d'en
faire quand ça a été ton métier
c'est terrible en fait
c'est complètement différent enfin moi
les échecs j'en ai fait depuis je suis
gamin j'ai fait des centaines de
tournois enfin ça va quoi
c'est pas la même chose que quand je
joue au tennis où je me fais kiffer les
échecs c'est pas un kiff en fait pour
moi
je joue juste pour gagner en fait sinon
j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
alors que tennis j'y joue pour m'amuser
par exemple mais je peux jouer à
d'autres jeux
ou faire d'autres choses pour m'amuser
mais mais pas les échecs
à partir d'un moment c'est plus c'est
plus la même chose
est-ce que j'ai un nouveau pneu non plus
maintenant
je suis trop vieux maintenant j'apprends
plus assez vite
je joue pas mal au tennis
et au tennis pour gagner bah ouais c'est
ça en fait
les échecs t'amusent pas ou du moins pas
la même manière que tu t'amuses le
tennis bah moi les échecs ça m'amuse
quand je gagne en fait
le tennis ça va m'amuse quand je joue je
sais pas comment dire en fait c'est
différent
c'est pas la même
le même investissement c'est pas enfin
c'est ça rien à voir puis moi je peux
pas jouer aux échecs pour m'amuser sans
calculer sans machin sans mettre
d'intensité en fait je suis incapable de
jouer je suis obligé d'essayer de bien
jouer sinon j'y arrive pas du tout
mais c'est pas la même c'est pas la même
approche
mais si je devais jouer un tournoi pour
la peine ce serait la pick-up parce que
ça ça va être vraiment marrant
si je vais si je devais rejoindre un
tournoi d'échec ce serait celui-là perso
parce que ça va vraiment être cool
c'est vraiment un tournoi qui est fait
qui est pensé pour s'amuser
pas comme les tons à l'échec habituels
où c'est très très long et
où tu peux quand même perdre toute ta
journée de faire un peu chier là ça
assez rapide et il y aura des animations
à côté et tout ça va être assez sympa
et si tu es vraiment en tennis que tu
approcherais son jeu comme aux échecs ah
bah oui ah bah ce serait pareil en fait
si j'avais passé tout le temps à faire
du tennis ce serait pareil
en fait 5
position est un peu déséquilibrée on
sent qu'il y a beaucoup de pièces qui
peuvent taper le rock
ça peut aller très très vite très très
fort
et salut Théodore
ça peut être un coup ça aurait peut-être
été mon coup cavalier 5
je pense pas
même si c'est possible
pour quelqu'un rincer aux échecs du
conseil plutôt de prendre une place
spectateur ou en joueur la big up alors
soit les deux soit que spectateur
S
mais juste les Blitz c'est pas une
il n'y a pas de tournoi d'échec en blitz
quasiment
OK
quand même c'était pas sûr que ce soit
la meilleure option mais il a une belle
position il peut faire du Fou F4 tour C1
elle est taper sur sur les colonnes
taper un peu partout il a le fou qui
tape il a tout qui tape
il y a jamais de cavalier C2 il y a le
fou qui contrôle les cavaliers sont
bizarres là bas
prêtent de se réorganiser avec et c'est
si ce qui est des 5 mais la tour va
arriver en c'est un quand même ça va
taper fort je pense que faut F4 est un
joli coup simple
tu donnes pas obligé d'atteindre les
2009 ou tu t'en fous ah non je me donne
pour objectif de taper les 2009 Michel
c'est la plus belle le problème que j'ai
avec ça c'est que je suis quelqu'un de
très exigeant envers moi-même quand je
fais de la compétition et tout et là
l'objectif de 2009 je l'ai un peu pris
comme de la compète au début
le problème c'est la quantité de gens
qui trichent c'est qu'en fait c'est dur
de se donner à 100% et d'être sévère
envers soi-même et exigeant vers
soi-même comme je le suis normalement
quand je perds une quantité de partie
avec des gens juste qui allume
l'ordinateur donc le problème c'est que
la compétition n'est pas assez propre
pour que je puisse être sûr d'y arriver
en stream aussi oui bien sûr en stream
mais c'est dur d'être exigeant avec
soi-même et de certains je suis une
merde j'ai encore perdu j'ai encore
perdu des points quand il y a vraiment
une soirée j'ai regardé après sur 75
parties il y en a 12 ou 13 où les gens
ont triché contre moi enfin genre c'est
trop donc évidemment tu perds des points
et tes sévères envers toi-même mais bon
c'est des fois les proportions elles
sont énormes
vous pensez 7 pour le moment ça doit pas
marcher il y a tout reprend
mais il va juste améliorer la position
là il va gagner Sacha les les pièces je
vous ai expliqué les enjeux sont trop
mal placés bah là il faut penser ça par
exemple ça tape tout
et même cette riche constante
j'y arriverai un jour donc on va dire
100 % mais mais non mais dur sans la
triche 100%
après au bout d'un moment ça peut juste
me décourager
ça ça gagne pour Sacha ça égalise là il
a fait une très très bonne partie
on pourrait écrire un livre sur cette
partie et Sacha qui se barre oh bah il
va pisser ça va pisser là
il y a qu'une personne qui sont
qualifiées par poule à la biquette il y
aura quatre joueurs qualifiés par poules
mais la finale sera 20h donc oui si tu
hésites entre joueurs et spectateurs je
te conseille de prendre spectateur
mais en soit je te conseille plutôt de
prendre les deux
bises plus ravito ouais
pas possible de contrôler la triche hein
c'est impossible sur Internet c'est
impossible il y a pas de bannière en
fait c'est les gens réel c'est difficile
mais mais c'est là là c'est
on est proche d'impossible
suffit que tu fasses 4 500 full-traire
des full focus sur stream si tu peux
atteindre les 2009 à simplement
pas sur pas sûr parce que tu vois j'ai
on va dire si je prends un mois
tranquille et que j'arrête de bosser et
que je m'occupe pas de ma femme et de ma
fille et tout ouais j'y arrive
mais
4 5 sessions full focus ok il faut voir
aussi combien d'heures dans la nuit ou
tout le boulot que j'ai eu à faire avant
tu peux full focus mais tu es tellement
fatigué que tu peux pas
faut vraiment être dans des bonnes
conditions parce que j'ai peu de marge
et faut pas que ça triche aussi parce
que en fait ça peut vite me démoraliser
vraiment il y a plusieurs sessions il y
a plusieurs jours là il y a trois
semaines où j'étais peut-être à 28
20-2830 et vraiment peut-être trois
quatre fois d'affiche je me suis fait
défoncer par des tricheurs
les gens qui se sont bannes est-ce que
tu récupères les points très rarement
quels sont les niveaux bas du tournoi il
y aura-t-il des joueurs à 121500 ouais
il y aura des jours à 21500 façon c'est
un système suisse le tournoi donc
il y a neuf parties une si vous êtes
moins fort si vous êtes très 11400 vous
allez avoir zéro sur 3 ou 0 sur 2 et
vous allez commencer à jouer contre des
joueurs de votre niveau mais
enfin je sais pas vous avez la chance
quand même de jouer contre un backy ou
quoi en tournoi ça me paraît fou de de
pas tenter le coup est-ce que tu
apprends quelque chose être position aux
gens qu'on détricheurs absolument rien
c'est important rien ça te fait perdre
du temps en fait c'est tout
bon on est dans une pause un petit peu
impromptue
pourquoi pas
après 45 minutes de jeu la mi-temps du 5
+ 5 ils ont décidé de s'arrêter
vessie doit
peut-être ça allait chier en fait
peut-être que ça chie côté joueur
comment tu reconnais des coups d'ordi
bah tu es jamais sûr mais bon quand ça
joue trop fort tu dis qu'il y a un
problème mais tu es pas sûr à 100%
il peut y avoir des contrôles sur ton PC
ça empêchera pas tricheur donc dans un
autre PC mais ça permettrait de réduire
un peu la triche ouais bah ils vont
utiliser un autre PC enfin ils
trouveront toujours une manière en
réalité
et puis bon cheesecom ils vont pas se
mettre à espionner les ordinateurs des
gens
j'ai pas encore sûr d'être dispo
l'audidé sans pour être prendre une
place directement où il se passe en cas
désistement
[Musique]
très difficile ça de dire
très difficile à marc de café
mais il restera peut-être des places
ouais
je sais pas combien il reste de place je
crois qu'il reste 40 places spectateurs
quelque chose comme ça je peux vous
remettre le lien mais je pense qu'ils
vont partir beaucoup demain avec le
match de mvl contre nepo parce que 40
places il en reste pas beaucoup en
réalité
il doit rester une quarantaine de places
ça va repartir le match je suis en train
je suis en train de chercher les je suis
en train de chercher la billetterie
je sais pas si c'est reparti je passe
ça peut que ça rejoue
non ça rejoue pas
spectateur je vais les remettre les
places spectateurs
fournissant FFE pour jouer non il faut
juste un compte chasse comme mais tu
peux à la rigueur même si tu l'as pas le
créer c'est gratuit
pourrais-je remet le lien pour la
billetterie mais ça va vraiment être
extraordinaire le la finale va être
incroyable
ça va être absolument incroyable
donc n'hésitez pas à prendre vos places
là spectateur vraiment fin non mais tous
vaut le coup si vous voulez jouer mais
si vous sentez que vous avez pas le
niveau prenez que une place spectateur
sans qu'il se passe cramé bref
si tu es vraiment nul aux échecs tu vas
te faire cramer
mais si tu vois genre Baki pourrait
monter à 300 sans se faire cramer par
exemple mais toi tu vas te faire cramer
je pense pas que la triche toi aussi
omniprésente ouais mais pas à ton niveau
et c'est surtout sur Internet
façon c'est présent dans tout à la
triche ne crois pas hein dans tout ce
que tu feras dans ta vie il y aura
beaucoup de triche
que ce soit dans le sport mais aussi
dans ta dans ta vie de tous les jours
il y a toujours des gens qui ont des
cheat codes en fait dans tout
rien juste à te blindé à la naissance
c'est un cheat code en fait
tu vas réussir à tout faire beaucoup
plus facilement que les autres
toujours moi perso j'ai commencé à
travailler à 18 ans tu vois c'est
tu as des gens ils ont jamais besoin de
travailler de leur vie tu vois je sais
pas il y a des cheat code dans tout
donc moi je le prends pas trop comme ça
c'est une minorité de gens quand même
qui triche et tu te fais quand même
kiffer après
évidemment là le jeu il a un petit peu
en crise et il faut vraiment qu'il y ait
une prise de conscience au niveau des
instances mais ça va ça va arriver petit
à petit
mais après tu peux venir jouer la
pick-up là il y aura pas de triche ou en
tout cas on aura vraiment une vraie
chance de choper les gens qui trichent
puisqu'on pourra vérifier physiquement
ce qu'ils font
sur ce genre d'événements on est plus ou
moins tranquille
le Maroc qui craigne la Belgique mais
ils ont eu la possession dans les Belges
ils ont eu la possession
fou Yanna la big up il y aura du il y
aura du Baki donc ça peut partir à tout
moment
et peut-être pas que anal
66 personnes possession pour la Belgique
ah bah ouais il y a eu la possession
importante important la possession au
football
ça fait mal l'IRL fulgurétral ouais mais
bon je pense que la fouille c'est
obligatoire pour les tournois d'échecs
on sait jamais qu'il y a une puce dans
l'urètre
qu'est-ce que ça fait mal ça je crois
que c'est une des trucs qui fait le plus
mal
bon c'est une petite petite anglaise
ça tape un peu le cheval je pense c'est
aussi si si le coup ou cavalier non ça
va être aussi fou G7
gris chat qui réfléchit
il se rappelle plus
c'est vous que je me connecte ça parle
plug et fouille mais bon
tu te connectes toujours au bon moment
il a saoulé de passer rappeler ou alors
il se rappelle et juste il aime pas la
ligne pour une raison concrète
content que tu comptes le tournoi ben
écoute merci à toi voilà je commande que
de match du premier tour après j'ai trop
de choses à faire
je sais pas pourquoi la pendule c'est
pas enclenchée je vais je vais enlever
le chrono en fait
ouais Sacha qui est saoulé de la
variante soit il se rappelle pas soit il
aime pas
et vu sa tête c'est plutôt il se
rappelle pas
ce qui est clair c'est ce qu'il fait un
peu chier c'est qu'il a pas fougé 7 à
cause de cahier français 5 et peut-être
qu'il peut faire B6 puis fouger 7 mais
si tu connais pas c'est hyper dangereux
et ça se voit que Ding il connaît
c'est beau ça la petite victoire du
Maroc ça fait plaisir
ça doit suer belge
ça doit suer côté belge je crois que
quoi que
ils sont très heureux
il faut les mains sur Twitter les Belges
ça peut
ils sont une chance je pense qu'ils ont
une chance ils avaient fait match nul
ils avaient gagné le premier ils ont
gagné le premier match en zéro donc
contre le Canada
en faisant un match de merde
donc nous ils sont pas du tout éliminés
qui est prend ses trois pions prend B6
qui a la position est vraiment
compliquée
ouais chute est un coup je dirais oui
mais je l'aurais pas joué
genre l'impression d'être trop en retard
pour un coup comme moi je suis
mais après ça peut
il l'a fait mais l'ordi aime pas du tout
je peux vous le dire
pense avoir le temps de faire cahier
français 3 et E5 mais c'est juste
complexe
après les Belges vont récupérer
peut-être Lukaku non prochain match ça
peut faire une diff
alors dis qui fait escudam B5
ça tape tout de suite
il se passe quoi sur qui est français 3
puis on prend ces trois faut prendre ces
trois tourbé un juste
à le roi noir est tellement faible et
puis on s'est cinq et dur à défendre
c'est dur
ça peut donner un truc comme ça dame 7
c'est pas la partie mais je suis en
train de réfléchir il faut F6 prise
et quelque chose comme tours C1 c'est
dur on est très en retard et le roi noir
est faible
il jouait Lukaku
ça doit être sûr alors
terrible
terrible position pour Sacha mais ça
c'est vu tout de suite un de la sortie
de l'ouverture il était pas bien là faut
cliquer
il va prendre et fouger 5
secondes contre 258 j'ai l'impression
que jingle a un peu plus fort quand même
Sacha j'ai l'impression qu'il est un peu
plus en réaction dans le match
il a l'air de plus pouvoir
mener des parties de A à Z quoi que la
précédente la victoire de grichu qui
avait été assez forte
et assez sympa
on va voir de toute façon le match
il dure encore plus de deux heures et
demie à mon avis
ce qui va rester
il doit rester encore un bon 40 minutes
une heure une heure il y a encore deux
heures trente de match on a le temps
qui calcule il a une belle position il
faut la terminer il est mieux autant
le plus une seconde permet pas vraiment
de remonter ici
est-ce qu'on peut dire que Sacha la
position même pas vraiment même pas
vraiment
un peu un Sacha réaction ou un Ding qui
qui appuie un peu quand il veut
maintenant il va mettre la tour en C1
Sacha menace prise ici je pense pas il y
aura tour 1
sachant petite en petite difficulté
mais digne qui se met mal au temps
ça peut tourner
elle a faut qu'il clique Sacha
my clique pas il clique pas assez
KBK bien joué menace cavalier C2
et surtout C1 il doit vouloir faire un
truc comme B6 c'est fou D7 qui enferme
la dame je pense que c'est son idée
il laisse cavalier C2 faut qu'il clique
là Sacha il clique pas du tout il clique
pas en fait
allez faut cliquer
allez faut cliquer clique c'est bien il
clique
allez Toro 8 il replace les pièces elle
est importante ça là si la défend il
fait un peu tourner la dynamique clique
clique non il clique pas il clique pas
assez
clique clique clique clique clique
c'est pas possible il clique pas allez
la clique il y a les reclic
clic il a cliqué encore il reclic
allez faut envoyer les pièces sur le roi
allez Sacha faut pas tomber
faut cliquer allez ça y est il défend
joueur de belette avant tout
il fait mal il fait mal Ding allez Sacha
qui essaie péniblement de remonter en
provoquant des prises
mais ça joue très proprement côté côté
Ding
ça va gagner
il a excellente jouer avec quelques
secondes il a et ce qui s'est un sourire
d'inglyrène
et ça repart
Sacha qui a pas complètement réussi à
sortir la Dame des deux fous pour H6
c'était bien joué
ah ouais Ding qui a vraiment été très
très fort la quand il restait plus de
temps
va me Détroit c'est pas un mystique sur
DC il doit vouloir d'apprendre
pas sûr
je sais pas ce que c'était peut-être
dame plutôt
c'était pas plus 3 secondes ça a
toujours été plus sain hein
Sacha qui se concentre
qui essaye de se rappeler de quelque
chose là ça se voit
le match est serré pour le moment 3-2
dingly Rennes
réussit pas à s'envoler le joueur
chinois mais attention
c'est toujours lui un qui a réussi à
faire à prendre la tête il a pas réussi
à faire le break encore
dans ce match
Alexander semble être en légère pression
Sacha qui a l'air heureux là de son coup
d'âme C3
il va vouloir mettre un cavalier en E5
et commencer à taper sur des cases
blanches
et j'imagine que l'idée sur cavalier E5
c'est de jouer fouder 5 pour essayer de
bloquer justement ces cases blanches
c'est assez finement joué de la part de
Ding
pour le moment il réalise un il réalise
son match le joueur le joueur chinois
très solide
[Musique]
avait failli batnaka
et là on voit il joue vraiment bien il
viendra jouer du côté de vaicanzé cette
année
sera lui qui sera le
challenger entre guillemets Diane et
paumes pour le titre de champion du
monde
qui a 5 bien joué
il tape un peu partout il tape sur
beaucoup de cases
on voit le placement de pièces c'est bon
il faut calculer les fous des 5 faut
prendre des 5 ca va les prendre et 5 il
y a peut-être même des fous prends le 7
là dessus
c'est compliqué
donc il fait fouder 6 pour s'enlever le
fou des vis-à-vis il reste dans le
vis-à-vis mais il est dans un des deux
vis à vie mais il est maintenant protégé
il est plus il est plus à la merci d'une
prise
donc faut des 6 ça semble être un bon
coup
des footing tape ouais mais bon un
simple dame G3 peut vraiment venir tout
couvrir à noter que le pion F pour le
moment on peut pas se déplacer
position et quand même pas évidente pour
pour les Noirs c'est pions isolés là ils
sont difficiles à jouer généralement on
préfère avoir une structure avec le pion
aussi qui renforce un peu le rock quand
même
là c'est vraiment difficile je trouve
pour Dingle position et
relativement désagréable
après Sacha une minute de retard
maintenant digne si mes Punto il va
faire très très mal parce que ce sera le
premier break
Sacha vraiment besoin de la gagner
celle-là mais là il semble un peu
planter
il trouve pas ce qu'il veut trouver
faire coulisser tout le 3 ça peut être
une option ouais
3 peut être un coup éventuellement
c'est pas une mauvaise idée en soi
c'est pas une mauvaise idée il a fait
tout radin bon c'est un bon coup la tour
était mal placé un coup de préparation
entre guillemets
c'est logique
on va voir un Siri
à faire la différence cavalier des 5
va peut-être partir avec un damage 3
à 3 fousses C2 menaces
il y a des cinq c'est pas mal joué ça
fait une une découverte voilà Sacha qui
est un peu implosé ça se voit
il bug là
il bug
c'est terrible
là le bug est terrible il a fait d'âme
c'est un
et effectivement la c'est les pièces
noires qui vont pouvoir venir attaquer
c'est catastrophique
enfin catastrophique c'est pas perdant
mais on voit les pièces noires là qui se
rapprochent du roi et la pendule qui
qui tourne trop pour Sacha
ça peut peut-être être le premier écart
dans ce match il faut qu'il réussisse à
réagir là avec ce cavalier 5S fou B3
quand même qui offre un certain jeu mais
il réussit pas à faire passer il y a
jamais de cake 1 F7 tours F7 tours 7 il
y a toujours le une pièce qui revient
boucher le jeu en dessin
alors il fait des 5 stratégiquement qui
est quand même intéressant parce que ça
bloque les pièces noires et ça bloque le
pion c'est 7 ça c'est un bon coup mais
je vois un peu tard
jouer un petit peu tard par Alexander
une 52 contre 22 secondes
mais bon au moins il y a plus de coups
facile
il peut menacer des six ouais
il peut commencer par un dame G5 digne
pour taper peut-être amener une tour en
8 pour taper le cheval
ça peut être une idée
d'Inger réflexion
ça suit un peu côté Ding là il avait il
avait une minute 52 avant ce coup il est
déjà une minute de réflexion quasiment
à calculer probablement D6 il doit avoir
une idée sur des 6
c'est pas ce que Sacha va faire il
hésite à envoyer des six il commence par
G3
et là l'idée Ding c'est à peu
j'allais dire de prendre un F2 mais
après dans ma vie sur un cavalier F3
donc il fait cavalier prend des 5 dames
c'est 5 c'est 6 va être forcé
mais il y a peut-être cavalier prend ses
6 Sacha qui va peut-être s'en sortir
on sent que c'est possible pour Sacha
à chaque fois
pour ça que je disais que si digne
commence à gagner une ou deux game ça
peut faire mal à l'idée c'est que sur
Full français 6 dames français 6
tu reprends un tour reprend B3 il y a
tout revu à la fin
qui gagne sur la 8e rangée digne qui a
plus que 20 secondes
à la salle devrait suffire pour Sacha la
position a l'air tellement dur à jouer
pour Ding maintenant
il trouve ce cavalier F6 qui est
peut-être le seul coup
pour rester un peu en vie
mais même complètement rester en vie
d'ailleurs
il y a pas de manière de taper là côté
blanc
pourtant on était bien organisé on avait
l'impression qu'on réussirait à faire
sauter quelque chose mais le cavagnon F6
qui veille
il va essayer de jouer pour tout re cinq
dame prend à 5 peut-être pour ces 5 il
empêche l'idée Dame des trois pour la
finale
attention il y a quand même un manque de
temps pour les deux hommes maintenant il
veut du tout recette
il va partir avec tout recettes ici ou 5
menace fouet peut-être pour tout
reprendre à 5 ça va partir avec food
étroits H7 et ça tombe
et Sacha qui s'en sort une nouvelle fois
mais on sent qu'il est il a la limite
Alexander
une
occasion
mais tout le problème pour Ding c'est
que chaque fois qu'il rate ses occasions
là il
il laisse peut-être une chance à Sacha
un moment donné de lui envoyer une
et de se remettre dans le sens de la
marche
dans reste à peu près 20 minutes dans
cette cadence
genre destinienne couleur inversé
du coup est plutôt un genre de bassinata
casting
de la partie précédente c'était vraiment
un moment donné en faveur de Ding mais
Sacha qu'avec peu de temps sur la
pendule là réellement jouer quasiment
que les meilleurs coups
est censé prendre la domination avec la
carence qui se réduit je pense pas
je pense c'est qu'il y aurait tout le
long
si quelqu'un je suis mort ouais ouais
Sacha qu'un jour assez expressif
j'ai l'impression qu'il a du mal à se
rappeler dans les ouvertures
là il donne un pion mais peut-être pas
vraiment genre cavalier prend puis on
prend dame prend
d’âme prend fou prends
car elle est B4 fois 4 F5
il a peut-être à 3 je sais pas c'est
compliqué donc peut-être avec tout re 8
alors 8 et sur F3 F5 ouais
allez c'est pour ça qu'il essaie de se
rappeler
Ding qui connaît plus ou moins encore en
tout cas qui est au courant des thèmes
mais je pense qu'il s'est rappelé là
Sacha
ça ressemble à quoi dit égal ça
ça ressemble à quoi j'y =
quelque chose ça doit être ça doit être
marrant standard de voir leur tête ouais
après le truc c'est que Sacha il se fait
trop enfin maintenant il se fait trop
souvent arnaquer
nul comme position c'est quand même les
blancs encore un qui tapent parce que
ils sont en avance sur le développement
il sait qu'il est légèrement moins bien
à cause de ce sujet de qui tape
surprend B2 il y a tourbé un qui est en
B7 c'est les blancs qui touchent en
premier
ça t'as souvent des positions qui
ressemblent à ça alors dites ça va c'est
tellement un enfer à jouer en réalité
c'est tellement dur
il a Sacha sur cette cadence il a
30009124
ça protège le pion B7 ça touche un peu
le cheval mais j'allais vous dire
attention à tout Reims
ça va mettre un vis-à-vis
ce qui va faire fouet 5 attention aussi
à ses vis-à-vis là qui peuvent tomber le
long de la grande diagonale
une nouvelle fois avec les Noirs
Alexander qui arrive pas à
sortir de ses schémas des schémas d'invy
Rennes jouer excellent bien
il est généralement extrêmement précis
avec ses fianchetto
connu pour dingleren
joueur
fort en tactique et on se rappelle qu'il
avait battu ma caméra dans cette partie
décisive à la dernière ronde des
candidats
avec un schéma un peu un peu ressemblant
avec ce fou G2 là qui avait qui avait
tapé fort il avait battu Douda aussi
avec ce fou G2
c'est un maître en la matière
d'une car assez facile
on le sent dominant
on le sent dominant d'inglyrène
mais il a les coups il a les coups dans
ces structures là qui lui viennent les
bons coups lui viennent tellement
naturellement c'est impressionnant
il a une compréhension de ses positions
là qui est stratosphérique
voilà il est content et il a de nouveau
l'avantage au temps ouais il domine
il domine fort
[Musique]
et tu t'imposes un nouveau massage dans
cette structure
c'est dur à yigrichou au supplice
là il y a du B7 qui marche déjà
c'est un joueur exceptionnel dans ces
dans ce type de position je crois
vraiment que on peut on peut pas faire
mieux
c'est du top top
du top top joueur
il prend son temps mais qui prend B7 a
l'air de marcher après c'est pas le seul
coup il est même pas obligé de le faire
il le fait la domination est-elle il
fait tomber le Punto
et cavaliers prend des huit incroyables
il prend trois pièces
il est pas obligé d'échanger en réalité
avec une finale un petit peu supérieure
qui est prend des 8 parce que s'il avait
fait apprendre B3
peut-être qu'on pouvait prendre ces 7
prendre ses 6 récupérer B2 et même si on
perdait à 7 on arrivait à s'en sortir
mais la cavalier prend des 8 extrêmement
bien joué
il joue sur le clouage et sur cavalier
prend des 8 enfin ce qui est prend D8 il
va prendre en B3 et sinon il va jouer
sur les découvertes pour aller encore
choper la tour à 8 c'est une Master
Class de dingly Rain ah mais il est il
est beaucoup trop fort dans ses
positions
il est au dessus il est tout simplement
au dessus Ding avec son fiancetto et là
Sacha
on le voit à son visage qui est dépité
ah le niveau de jeu de dingue
un calcul
qui va tomber
Sacha qui doux ouais
j'ai pas trop son espoir
parce que s'il perd le fou B7
matériellement il va être trop derrière
et dames C3 il va juste y avoir tout
rose C1
on voit Sacha qui est en train de
se faire défoncer
il va être obligé d'abandonner ici plus
de temps
et plus de pièces
qui fait le taf à une nouvelle fois
Sacha avec les Blancs d'inky réfléchit
il a eu des problèmes dans l'espagnol
depuis tout à l'heure
allez petite berlinoise
va Sacha qui marque un temps d'arrêt qui
essaye de se rappeler de sa prépa ou en
tout cas de décider de la bonne variante
et ce sera la finale de la berlinoise
pour le joueur russe important de partir
encore un
qui est vraiment
tellement fort tellement puissant
d'ingeren
tellement propre dans danser avec
fiancéto
il faut vraiment que ça chat réussisse
une nouvelle fois casser la défense de
Digne parce que si il fait nul dans
celle-là et qui perd la prochaine
digne va commencer à pouvoir construire
sa victoire sur
sur sephianketo
toujours pareil en cette berlinoise
visuellement les blancs sont beaucoup
mieux mais la réalité tout autre
position est compliquée même si c'est
dangereux à jouer au noir
il touche très vite très vite les coups
en plus dingue c'est
à l'année dernière c'est le seul à avoir
mis en danger et en grand danger n'aura
bon il jouait en pleine nuit etc enfin
il était pas sur des bons horaires et
tout et donc il était très désavantagé
quand même je trouve mais il aurait pu
il aurait pu gagner
il aurait pu l'emporter
contre Nakamura et c'est le seul qui a
il a été plus que proche il emmenait en
tie-break
Ding était gagnant bah il aurait dans le
dominait le match contre Nakamura
après
dominer n'est pas gagné mais il avait il
avait dominé ce match ouais contre Naka
et c'était incliné il s'était incliné
quand même mais en taille break
et c'est le seul à part Magnus qui l'a
battu qui a réussi à mettre Naka en
danger dans un speech
c'est quoi les plans de cette finale ben
pour les Noirs bloqués les l'avancée des
pions
sur case blanche et pour les blancs les
avancées en gros
mais ça joue tout sur les cases blanches
parce que les Blancs n'ont pas de foot
casse blanche
donc ça joue tout là-dessus
genre est-ce que tu as le temps de faire
Rouger deux rois G3 F4 F5 ou pas
maladie qui casse tout de suite la
structure
on voit un les blancs qui ont
une structure de pion plus propre à
l'ailera mais le problème c'est qu'elle
est dure à avancer pour le moment
digne qui calcule
il va peut-être perdre l'option C7 mais
il va pouvoir générer de l'activité avec
sa paire de fou
complexe
il va pas vouloir donner ce pion C7 mais
on est peut-être obligé
compliqué en tout cas
à noter qu'il a pas le droit de faire
grand rock s'il va faire [ __ ] ranger 5
ah attends j'ai un il a foi H4 bien joué
donc il est changé il va peut-être faire
cavalier F4 maintenant
ouais la question c'est ce qu'on a le
temps d'attaquer ce roi
qui peut être attaqué par du cavalier F4
tour H1 tours essayer de le prendre
de côté Sacha qui qui se pose des
questions le fou c'est 8 qui peut pas
sortir proprement des 7 il sera quand
même assez laid
ouais c'est peut-être le seul coup
d'essai donc il menace pas grand rock le
roi a déjà bougé c'est quand même un
détail important
je me demande si tout rachat est un coup
ici c'est le coup jouer ça menace quand
même tourage 8
pour gagner la tourelle
c'est proche de gain
Sacha qui pourrait une nouvelle fois
recoller au score
de justesse
bref
c'est étonnant il a réussi à mettre un
set up en place
il fait tout rein il veut cavalier 6
maintenant pour cavalier français 7
et donc là on veut cavalier aussi touche
la tour
et tourage 16 tours français 7
ou cavalier français 7 directement parce
que ça va venir contrôler aussi la case
G7 qui est crucial
ce qui est assez crucial
il fait Torcé 8 sur cavalier ici s'il
veut quoi
peut-être torche 8 et 3G 6
Sacha qui est étonné un coup perdu
parce que là la position est vraiment
jolie pour les blancs
[Musique]
devrait rester une partie après si mes
calculs sont bons je sais pas exactement
combien de temps a duré la pose
mais il devrait rester encore une partie
derrière
allez on va voir on va voir ce qui joue
Sacha
tourage 7 peut-être mais tourrage 7
tours G7 ça a l'air de tenir mais
vraiment sur le fil et qui va lui aussi
storger 8 orages 7 3 G6 peut-être qu'il
va lui aussi quand même qu'est-ce que
comment on leur dit défend
Tanger sixtouage 7 3g8 pour C7 pour C7
cavaliers 7 x 7 et il bloque le cavalier
ouais c'est vraiment du bol
c'est les variante que Sacha du calcul
et il a fait tout rage 6 du coup
il maintient dingly Rennes dans une
boîte
allez il a réussi à doubler les tours
sur la colonne h
du coup Ding qui revient avec son rond
F7 pour pas se faire bloquer
plus qu'une minute pour Sacha
ça va être dur
elle est importante celle-là il doit
continuer à répondre à Ding qui lui a
mis la grosse pression avec les
fiancetto
on est égaliteux autant maintenant digne
qui réalise une défense incroyable
trois bien joué il veut revenir en E5
à la joie un coup
joue un coup et juste dur en fait
F4 il file le pion pour fouder 7 pour
essayer de remettre son fou vers F5
bonne
idée pratique ca valide des trois
menaces plus vraiment cavaliers 5
maintenant donc tour G8 il veut
contre-attaquer en G2 plus que 20
secondes pour les deux hommes
les chèques en âge 7 qui peut faire mal
ton G7 ça échange une paire de Tours
égalité matérielle
et la récupérer le pion
il veut rentrer dans cette finale mais
il y a peut-être tout reprendre non il y
a du Fou F5 peut-être
pas facile de savoir si le pion passé va
suffire
F3 c'est bien joué la position semble
magnifique pour les blancs l'ordinateur
affiche un 0-0 complètement égal
mais très franchement ça semble pas être
le cas quand on la voit à cette position
allez ça y est maintenant l'ordinateur
d'un avantage blanc le roi monte fort
tout ça grâce à ce pion passé que les
noirs n'ont pas et là cavalier dessine
Co
roi F4 3c63.f3 roi français 7 les blancs
qui tapent les Punto en premier
et Sacha qui va réussir une nouvelle
fois égaliser dans ce match 4 partout
il est content Sacha je sais pas si
encore une partie ça se joue sur la pose
ouais la pose a duré plus de 4 minutes
et c'est la dernière partie du 5 + 1
Ding une nouvelle fois avec les pièces
blanches
qui va nous faire suer
Sacha qui maintenant lui réfléchit à
comment empêcher de digne d'avoir les
positions qu'il aime jouer c'est marrant
à ce petit jeu du chat et de la souris
avec les blancs et les noirs
il bloque sur le premier coup
il réfléchis à quel setup mettre en
place
et il relance
il joue pas ici il joue cavalier B6 la
position qu'il l'avait
mis en difficulté un petit peu plus tôt
dans ce match
pas bien c'est calculer en question de
temps les cadences
capacité à changer d'ouverture est assez
dingue bah ouais mais ils connaissent
tout
à ce niveau là ils connaissent tout
c'est incroyable
l'étendue de leur connaissance c'est
incroyable
et Sacha qui aime pas de nouveau cette
variante là il a fait kb6 mais
il montre les mêmes signes d'inquiétude
que lors de sa partie précédente dans
cette variante
ce que je peux expliquer le pourquoi du
nom de Sacha c'est le diminutif Sacha
d'Alexander en russe
décide de jouer avec pion de moins mais
une nouvelle fois il se fait prendre
dans l'ouverture Alexander
terrible
il se fait sans arrêt prendre
c'est juste un c'est juste un pion en
réalité
c'est juste un
il n'y a pas de réel compensation pour
le pion
est-ce que les deux joueurs se voient
ouais potentiellement ils peuvent ils
peuvent ouvrir la caméra je pense pas
qu'il le fasse parce qu'ils sont à mon
avis très concentrés sur les parties
mais théoriquement ils peuvent vrai
c'est pas tout à fait le même style que
Alexander grishuk mais ouais
c'est
[Musique]
une fille qui fait des stream des
streams sur twitch on voit les
connaisseurs
on voit les connaisseurs la dame est pas
enfermée elle peut toujours repartir en
B5 mais il essaye de l'enfermer
Sacha
c'est de quoi ça parle ah bah oui on
sait toujours de quoi ça parle tout le
monde sait toujours de quoi ça parle en
fait
mais connaisseurs
c'est bien ce qu'a fait
Grisha au lieu de souffrir contre le
fouger d'eux il a décidé de donner un
pion
pour pour jouer l'activité
essayer de jouer une un type de position
qui lui convient un petit peu mieux un
petit peu plus
c'est pas un choix ridicule
on sent que c'était pas ce qu'il avait
réellement envie de faire mais
mais c'est quand même bien fait
elle va jouer contre nepo demain ouais
va jouer deux mains contre Yann
nepomiashi dans un match au même format
qu'on commencera avec Baki
bon match
ce sera un beau match
jumul le positionner avec l'activité
je passe à chaque qui joue bien tous les
types de position il est même plutôt
positionnel je dirais dans son style de
base mais
là le souci c'est Dingle dans ses
positions à fionketto il est vraiment
extrêmement fort
et Sacha il réussit pas
il est trop dominé
c'est pas qu'il réussit pas c'est qu'il
est trop dominé par Ding et
donc dans cette confrontation là il
préfère partir sur sur ce genre de
choses et il a raison
dans cette confrontation là il considère
que c'est ce qui lui offre
les meilleures chances
bon après là il a toujours son pion de
moins et sa position est dure mais au
moins il
a moyen que que Ding fasse faute quoi
le placement là pour Alexander mais à le
problème c'est qu'il a un pion de moi
donc oui le fout des 5 est bon mais oui
mais tu as un pion moi
donc c'est dur
mais après au moins il a pas deux
minutes de retard comme dans les autres
parties où il était complètement aux
abois
et
c'est position il y a matière à faire
des gaffes pour digne donc concrètement
si on regarde cette partie par rapport
aux autres dans les mêmes ouvertures
c'est celle où il a les meilleures
chances quoi
c'est vraiment fort
ça fait extrêmement mal il y a pas eu
trop de nuls il y en a eu un petit peu
en début de match après simplement les
joueurs ont gagné
avec les Blancs juste je suis quasiment
que des victoires blanches là depuis
depuis 4 4 5 parties
c'est Sacha qui dans un premier temps
avait égalisé avec les Blancs et depuis
c'est victoire blanche sur victoire
blanche
si c'est Dame B4 il repart mais ça va de
nouveau être une victoire blanche ce
pion plus fait trop mal il y a en plus
B7 qui est mal le pion des 4 qui est
sous pression alors là pour le moment il
est encore défendu artistiquement
mais ça va de nouveau gagner au blanc
terrible
aucun des deux joueurs n'aura trouvé
l'antidote contre l'ouverture fétiche de
l'adversaire
digne qui aura beaucoup tourné dans les
Espagnols sans succès et Sacha qui aura
beaucoup tourné
dans ces genres de catalan sans plus de
succès
à moins qu'il réussisse à arnaquer
celle-là la dernière chance pour
le joueur russe
il garde des pièces il essaie de poser
des problèmes
mais c'est
de nouveau une domination
des pièces blanches
il a quand même réussi à remettre le
fond en Cessy ça cacher le rond à chute
cavalier G5 ouais c'est bien joué ça
vient taper sur la case 6
on le voit il se redresse sur sa chaise
il va peut-être aller prendre à 5 et
tenter un coup de poker
et là il y a cavalier prend B7
peut-être pas merci Léna peut-être il y
a pas de cavalier prend B7 ici
difficile à dire qu'il prend B7 pour
prendre B7
ça me prend B7
on reprend B7 dame prend B7 tout prend
B7 cavalier F7 qui prend des 6 qu'est-ce
que c'est bien joué de la part de dingue
ce cavalier prend B7 il fait mal
et là-dessus c'est 8 et il faut prendre
des 5
qui est chirurgical
gros match jusqu'à maintenant mais il
faudra qu'il réussisse à fermer
l'espagnol et attention pour lui un
contre Yann et pomyachi en finale de
championnats du monde si réussi pas à
être parfait contre l'Espagnol il va
suer
il se rappelle que même Carlson avait eu
quelques difficultés dans l'ouverture
dans cet Espagnol qu'il avait réussi à
combler par un niveau de jeu
nettement supérieur à celui de son
homologue russe
Sacha qui a de nouveau une position
merdique qui va de nouveau tenter
d'arnaquer dans le iPod
on verra ainsi le Bullet est à son
avantage ou pas en tout cas pour le
moment c'est
dinglieren qui règne en maître
semble légèrement favori de ce match
mais Sacha qui réussit à répondre à
chaque fois
et il réussit encore à obtenir une
position il pourrait peut-être arnaquer
quel niveau de jeu des deux hommes et là
il y a tort c'est 8 ça y est
digne qui réussit à tourner
du 5 + 1 avec un point d'avance 5 à 4
nous on va tourner une petite page de
pub et une publicité on se retrouve dans
cinq à dix minutes pour la suite du
match et le début de la cadence 3 + 1 à
tout de suite les amis
et voilà on est de retour les joueurs
sont de retour
prêt à en découdre
pré en découdre pour
cette phase de 3 + 1 les joueurs qui ont
tous les deux dominé avec les pièces
blanches ça a été difficile pour greachu
contre les fiancetto et difficile
pour
difficile avec pour contre les fiancés
on va avoir comment les deux hommes se
comportent en 3 + 1 je sais pas si ça
reprit non ça a pas repris
en fait c'est pas le speechestre c'est
le post-chasse
en fait il y a 10 minutes de il y a 5
minutes de pause à la mi-temps 10
minutes de pause entre les trucs
ils ont enlevé des parties pour ajouter
des pauses
ah le son il est bien à
les gens ont préféré l'ancien ils disent
que le son est moins chaud mais en
réalité moi je me suis réécouter le son
il est tellement pixel
le son il est vraiment pixel bon allez
ça repart ça repart dans ces Espagnols
les deux joueurs qui ont eu un petit peu
révisé entre
ça fait plug
c'est ce que je disais tu peux quand tu
prends le micro comme ça dans les mains
tu es confort
tu es très confort
très très confortable à déplacer
il est il est vraiment top
non mais c'est réel hein c'est réel
agréable au toucher
bon on va voir ce qu'il en est dans cet
Espagnol et ce que Ding a réussi à
fermer quelques problèmes
mais oui le son il est encore plus
fidèle à la réalité je sais pas comment
dire
en tout cas Ludwig entend la différence
et c'est ça le plus important en fait le
micro il est que pour Ludwig ah bah
ouais bah c'est pour ça en fait on peut
changer de micro pour lui faire plaisir
il y a plus de basse c'est pas mal ils
disent que en fait de ce que j'ai lu
mais j'ai l'impression que c'est vrai
mais je sais pas si je suis matrixé
parce que j'ai lu ou pas mais ils disent
que le
que le jour il améliore la voix de
manière moins fine que celui là
c'est quoi le format du match alors
c'est une heure et demie en 5 + 5 1h en
3 + 1
et une demi-heure en plus
mais j'ai ça qui bug je vais essayer de
mettre un chronomètre je sais pas
comment on chope vous savez comment
Chopin un chronomètre
on va essayer de s'en mettre
je sais qu'il y avait un site
de chronomètre de compte à rebours
je vais regarder en pendant que la
partie joue parce que c'est vrai que ça
continue à bugger
je ferai un effet de proximité
bon je vais récupérer un truc un peu
dégueu pour aujourd'hui on essaiera on
essaiera d'avoir mieux demain
parce que sinon en fait je vais passer
je vais passer le live à chercher un
compte à rebours propre
et je sais pas si ce compte à rebours là
est juste
enfin je sais pas si j'ai le bon timing
je pense pas
c'est un peu le système D mais
c'est mieux que rien
demain il y a quoi demain il y a mvl
demain il y a une veine
le micro c'est qu'il a choisi non mais
il est en fait c'est un micro très connu
en réalité lui et le jour c'est les deux
micros les plus utilisés pour pour le
casting
c'est qu'il favori de mvl n'est pas
selon le CP selon le CPU je sais pas
mais le favori c'est forcément des pots
mais c'est Maxime qui va gagner
potentiellement digne n'est pas en car
non je crois pas du tout il y avait le
tableau juste avant pendant la pause
mais non non c'est pas ce côté du
tableau
il y avait un souci avec le SM7 non il y
avait pas de souci
mais toute façon il me fallait un micro
supplémentaire et puis j'avais envie
d'un peu changé c'est mon petit plaisir
bah des fois je me fais un peu kiffer
quoi j'achète des trucs qui me font
plaisir là ça me faisait plaisir
d'entendre ma voix sur un autre micro de
voir un peu la DIF et il y a un réglage
possible celui-là mais j'arrive pas à
choper la différence en terme de son
il y a un petit bouton là
je sais pas du tout ce que ça change
malgré tout qui domine pas un nom
celle-là
tu devrais quoi pour les autres mais
objectivement je pensais 60-40 pour
dépôt
micro c'est pour le bouton c'est pour le
faire vivre et non je sais même pas s'il
y a une différence
tu connais rien de parier sur les
parties d'échec en France c'est interdit
par contre
ouais c'est interdit je crois en France
par largeur et après dans les autres
pays je sais pas on va voir si Ding joue
le gain ici ou pas
il est tenté de faire nul OK
normal il avait un pion de plus dans il
avait un pion passé éloigné mais il
décide de faire nul et là ça peut on va
voir ce que greachu lui a trouvé
à jouer pendant la pause
contre la Catalane
il y a pas une notice avec micro il y a
une notice ici avec ce bouton mais je
n'arrive pas à entendre la différence
que ça fait je sais pas si Ludwig a
entendu je pense pas
il a changé de variante il rentre dans
une catalane mais c'est position là
elles sont tellement dures à jouer
contre digne
Ludwige à moitié
emballé par le match
ah le speechers c'est une compétition
faut que ça faut que ça monte dans les
tours
c'est ça devient vraiment passionnant à
partir des cars
comme beaucoup de sport après là c'est
quand même le premier tour c'est le
temps de se chauffer mais après il va y
avoir de super match
ING dans ces positions il est tellement
dur à jouer j'ai l'impression que petit
à petit dingue en train de prendre le
dessus quand même
elle n'est pas un peu cliquer très fort
ouais complètement
il va y avoir du cavalier c'est quoi
trop maintenant
je suis dans le club des siècle qui
vient de perdre ma première partie en
interclub j'ai beaucoup de mal à gérer
la défaite as-tu des conseils
ouais mais tu les connais mes conseils
si tu as trop de stress faut faut
relâcher la pression quoi
comme toutes ces compétitions il faut
quand même un peu avancer dans la
compète pour
streamer quoi comme huitième le 2 matchs
celui-là et celui de demain de Maxime
contre les pots et après je streamerais
tous les matchs à partir des cars demi
et finales ou peut-être 3/4 sur 4 et les
demi les finales
c'est quoi qui tiennent le plus dans la
défaite moi ça me fait chier de perdre
mais bon après ça m'arrive tellement
souvent que
même plus grand chose à [ __ ]
mais après en vrai de vrai
ce qui détend le plus c'est de Ken mais
bon c'est premier degré mais après les
gens vont tomber dessus encore c'est ça
qui est catastrophique c'est qu'à chaque
fois que j'ai des trucs comme ça tu as
tout le monde qui me dit ouais Nani
nanana
non vrai c'est ce qui c'est ce qui
permet le plus de relâcher la pression
en fait
mais
après tout le monde va me tomber dessus
est-ce que c'est 5 jouable voilà c'est
dur ouais
c'est possible d'avoir l'évaluation non
on regarde on regarde la partie 100
ouais mais je sais que c'est je sais que
ça rentre kick vers le zoom et c'est la
vérité en fait c'est ce qui te permet le
plus
de souffler après
voilà c'est 5 à mon avis c'est l'idée
effectivement
mais bon les blancs sont mieux tu as
pris le centre tu as le faut 8 qui est
dégueu mais Ding il est vraiment un
jouable dans ses positions 2 minutes on
se contre 20 secondes il est il est
tellement fort dans ses positions de
type catalan c'est incroyable c'est
peut-être le meilleur joueur de
l'histoire des échecs dans ce truc là
c'est incroyable
il a une dextérité pour pour jouer
sefian Ketto et pour dominer petit à
petit ses adversaires qui est qui est
juste fantastique c'est phénoménal
si vous voulez progresser dans la
Catalane regarder les parties de Digne
c'est incroyable
j'ai réussi à améliorer ses pièces les
unes après les autres
Sacha là qui a décidé de faire ce qu'il
peut faire de mieux c'est à dire rien
mais il a réussi à tellement améliorer
sa sa position petit à petit
Sacha qui défend bien aussi il a décidé
de rien faire et ça c'est vraiment pas
bête
quant à aucun bon coup à jouer ne joue
rien
ouais c'est très très bien joué ce que
fait ce que fait Alexander et c'est 5 là
il a joué une énorme série de coups
il va refaire du cavalier fuite cavalier
mais ça continue à suer ça continue à
suer
il donne tout
tourage 3
B6 dans H4 est-ce qu'il va pouvoir
empêcher le mat
il peut encore dans ma je suis 3F 7 au
F37
Sacha qui
défend mais pas assez là il y a tour des
trois enfilade
trop dur pour Sacha
trop dur ah il souffre il souffre contre
Ding
ça te tenterait pas de monter un compte
de 500 en vrai long en commentant
chacune de tes parties c'est ce que je
fais sur ma chaîne
facile et c'est ce qu'on a fait
aujourd'hui encore
tu peux retrouver sur ma chaîne
blisterie facile
série de vidéos comme ça
il y en a déjà
on a déjà combien doit déjà y en avoir
une vingtaine quasiment
peut toujours remonter en belette je
pense qu'il aura du mal là s'il est il
faut pas que l'écart se creuse
espagnole est-ce que là il va y avoir
des quatre marrant les deux joueurs ont
réussi à trouver
le type de position il domine
mais pour le moment il y en a un des
deux qui a réussi à fermer le problème
et pas l'autre
ils ont dit une Irène en faisant nul
dans la première
réussit à remettre la pression sur Sacha
très fort
ça change tout c'est petit avantage
blanc à une nouvelle fois
on voit un petit avantage structurel
avec les pions au centre avec Dame C4
il va mettre la dame en C4 et on sait
six
là il pousse Sacha
complexe
complexe digne qui fait 6 pour taper sur
le pion en A5
difficile
il fait 5 pour toucher le cavalier jouer
cavalier C4 quand même il a donné le
pion pour l'activité
on sent qu'il est très à l'aise dans
dans ses positions
s'acharge et regarder les pions il y a
un pion de plus mais ils sont vraiment
vraiment moches cette tour pas très bien
placé les cases noires pour le cavalier
mais il est un peu moins en facilité que
d'ingly rain en réalité c'est ça la
différence c'est que Ding dans ces dans
ces catalanes on sent vraiment que c'est
tout le temps du jeu pour deux résultats
qui peut pas se rater au pire il annule
et Alexander on sent qu'il peut y avoir
un jour un problème
la domination est minime mais elle
existe
sur ces 8 il essaie de défendre il y a
peut-être cavaliers à trois maintenant
pour aller toucher à 6
pas sûr
tours il tape 6
tellement dur à jouer avec les noirs qui
étaient sains qui veulent laisser le
pion pour essayer de se débarrasser du
Fou
un match construit sur la Catalane
qui prend il échange tout
mais il y a un coup de répit pour les
noirs
pour défendre un peu ses pions peut-être
qu'il va faire cavalier B4 pour couvrir
l'option de C6 tours c'est 5 fait aussi
le travail
cavalier 5 il y a peut-être cavaliers F4
pour prendre ses 6 pour prendre 5
c'est bien joué de la part de Ding il va
encore une fois sauver le demi point
et dans un match où les deux hommes
dominent autant avec les pièces blanches
c'est pas une main ça faire
c'est vraiment tout échange en force et
faire nul
c'est logique
il va faire juste des allers-retours
en fait c'est vrai que nul est un bon
résultat donc
c'est pris par Ding et Sacha envoie un
déçu il sait que là maintenant
il va devoir défendre avec les Noirs il
faut qu'il arrête les noirs
ça fait trop de défaite là
ça fait trop de défaites et on regrette
de pas avoir pu voir un match entre
Timbi Rennes et Carlsen très franchement
j'aurais adoré voir cette affiche
et voir comment Carlson aurait réussi à
déstabiliser le joueur chinois qui à mon
avis en face à face à plus d'arguments à
faire valoir que des pommiers hachis
enfin quoi qu'il en soit même si Carlsen
n'avait pas joué avait décidé de jouer
son match championnat du monde ça aurait
pas été contreding mais bel et bien
contre Yann j'espère tout de même que si
Ding devient champion du monde on verra
un affrontement en deux entre les deux
hommes
avec in Carlson string à mon avis
aujourd'hui ce serait la plus belle
affiche de championnat du monde qu'on
pourrait avoir mais surtout avant le
confinement
qui pourrait être en difficulté dans les
ouvertures contre Yann
ça aurait pu être son problème contre
Karl scène aussi d'ailleurs
il est très très à l'aise dans ses
positions là il connaît très bien la
théorie et
il est simplement très fort
car ça n'est pas réputé en étant le
meilleur des ouvertures ouais c'est
forgé une fausse réputation de joueurs
pas très bien préparés alors que c'est
celui qui est le mieux préparé
probablement ou un des mieux préparés
mais il a réussi à se forger cette
réputation
de par sa stratégie de jouer des petites
lignes
il a réussi à faire croire entre
guillemets pendant un moment qui jouait
des petites lignes parce qu'il était pas
bien préparé
alors que
il y avait toujours des idées derrière
et de toute façon c'est
c'est aussi ça le jeu de haut niveau
c'est d'essayer de cacher au maximum
c'est fort
surtout dans les ouvertures et de cacher
des
c'est pas vraiment caché mais il a
réussi à se forger quand même cette
réputation
qui n'est pas réel
très malin
position est très complexe qui a réussi
à sortir un peu des schémas de catalan
habituel il y a peut-être se retrouver
dans des positions que que Ding Gérard
un peu moins précisément
Fabi qui était très bien préparé ouais
dans les grands événements mais on avait
vu dans son match de championnats du
monde dans le match champion du monde
qui avait opposé Carlsen à Caruana que
Carlsen n'avait pas été dominé de voir
les ouvertures par Carona peut-être même
l'inverse
le manque d'expérience et probablement
une équipe moins financée
ah c'est dur à dire
et puis on a toujours du mal à jauger
vraiment le niveau de Ding
j'ai l'impression que dans les derniers
tournois qu'il a joué notamment les
candidats il a surtout payé des mauvais
début de tournoi
à cause de difficultés j'imagine dans le
transport
c'est devenu très difficile de voyager
depuis la Chine
et donc on a du mal à me faire un avis
définitif sur le niveau de jeu de Ding
mais j'ai l'impression que quand il est
à son top il est dangereux après je
crois qu'il a pas très bon résultat
contre les pots
donc c'est difficile à dire c'est un
match assez assez difficile à
pronostiquer
probablement si tu devais mettre
quelqu'un au dessus tu mets traînépo
parce que il a il offre quelques
garanties mais
même pas parce que si mes potes perd la
première game on a vu comment ça pouvait
tourner
alors que Ding il pourrait revenir un
petit peu comme Carlson en fait
en position en tout cas on a une
position compliquée
c'est bien joueur du monde mais parfois
ça passe vraiment à côté Ding c'est pas
ça à côté que depuis le confinement
avant ça passait rarement à côté c'était
celui qui était
lancé pour pour aller affronter Magnus
très clairement
après voilà il y a eu tous cette
histoire covid etc qui est toujours pas
terminée en Chine d'ailleurs
là il faut vraiment que ça charge
réussisse à la gagner celle là il a une
vraie chance
bien jouéca 4
d'un Français ça tu peux faire [ __ ] en
un allez là c'est peut-être l'occasion
pour Sacha
attention à foi si si un X6 dans ma
chute à fougée 7
allez Sacha qui est mieux autant là il
faut
il faut faire quelque chose ici
est-ce qu'il y a pas prise il prend F2
ah je pensais qu'il prendrait un risque
Alexander y est peut-être des choses
avec foot avec tous ces trois mais bon
c'était pas évident celle-là de finale
elle paraît vraiment bien nulle par
contre
les blancs qui peuvent récupérer un pion
mais qui vont pas pouvoir
faire fructifier leur majorité
Sacha qui doit être content de ce demi
point quand même et c'est la pause déjà
c'est déjà la pause
avec sans parti sans défaite 21
victoires 117 nuls digne possédait le
record de partie sans défaite avant la
série de Carlsen ouais série qui avait
été arrêté par un certain Maxime Vacher
Lagrave d'ailleurs de mémoire
qui avait stoppé cette longue série
dans un tournant en Chine je pense
mais Maxime qui avait sorti une partie
très tactique contre Ding et qui avait
réussi à le
le faire vaciller
quasiment en train de qui depuis qu'il
coachent plus car roana et je sais pas
un peut-être mvl qui sait
qui
sait on ne sait pas
je me rappelais bien
je me rappelais bien de cette partie
magnifique victoire de Maxime
ça commence quand ça reprend quand je
sais pas quand ça reprend
je sais pas trop comment il marche avec
ses pauses là en milieu de
de segments c'est des trucs qui ont été
rajoutés ça
avant ça a joué non stop
c'est quand même elle peut avoir le
titre ouais bien sûr bien sûr qu'il le
peut
on attend le retour du match ils font
ces petites pauses maintenant
ça va être dur pour grichou quand même
je pense
complexe
on attend
savoir partir je pense que les joueurs
regardent un petit peu là
d'en profiter
qui se passe quoi ben je sais pas ils
font une pause
pour qu'il faut je sais parler ils font
je l'autre pause la comprenais mais là
j'étais je pensais pas qu'il se ferait
une pause aussi longue comme ça en plein
milieu
au milieu
non c'est moi qui est mon chrono qui
continue à tourner
à les mettre sur pause
il restait 34 minutes non 33 on va le
remettre vers 32 hein on sait pas
exactement
mais ouais non c'est un peu long là
on s'en fout on attend mais
la pause est réellement longue
déjà que les matchs sont longs
pourquoi ils font pas un système de 7
comme nous en fait
c'est tellement mieux
bon après on s'en fout c'est pas c'est
pas notre guerre c'est pas notre
problème
ouais c'est étonnant de si tu veux faire
autant de pause de pas faire un truc de
au pire tu fais en 3 7 gagnant
si tu veux que le match dure
mais c'est beaucoup mieux les sept
ça rythme beaucoup mieux les matchs a
beaucoup plus de hype c'est beaucoup
plus intéressant
là il y aura eu des balles de 7 à 2 2 3
3 là ça dans les deux trucs ça aurait
fait des morts subites ça aurait été
très amusant
canon est la poche je crois qu'elle est
automatique la pause
allez ça repart
ça repart sur une espagnole
je crois qu'elle est automatique parce
que dans les deux
les deux fois elle était à la moitié des
des portions
OK
qui va essayer de retrouver un avantage
avec les blancs dans l'espagnol
il reste 24 minutes je pense pas qu'ils
puissent rester 24 minutes map 35A
ils ont peut-être oublié eux aussi de
leur chronomètre
parce que le match a repris vers les 17
heures quelque chose
et la pause a duré du temps donc il y a
pas eu 36 minutes de jeu ici
il a joué ces trois
il va sûrement jouer
le cavalier mais pas sur
il a fait 3 OK
et des seins quoi les Noirs là ont tapé
au centre en premier riding qui a réglé
ses problèmes dans l'espagnol
ça va vraiment être compliqué pour
pour Sacha
il réussit à plus être dominer avoir des
positions qui se jouent
il va pouvoir éventuellement faire une
expansion là avec du F5
tension après de pas trop ça fait bien
les cases côté Ding
en tout cas il chasse le cavalier
position ils sont toujours dures à
évaluer
première vue tu as toujours l'impression
que les noirs sont bien parce que il y a
l'Espace il y a ce qui ont des trous un
peu bizarre mais en réalité
du D4 qui peut partir à un moment donné
complètement faire exploser la position
noire
on essaie de taper le Pione 5 évidemment
il l'attaque est-ce qu'il va y avoir un
coup comme d'hab c'est ça ici pour
défendre
il a fait dame F6
protège le Punto
il revient il a complètement blindé et
là c'est difficile pour pour Sacha
le match qui est en train complètement
lui échapper
là c'est difficile pour
pour Sacha qui est en train de voir Ding
maîtriser avec les pièces noires
il hésite entre rois chutes et rouages 7
Royal futur reste un peu plus dans le
cavalier et dans les tours roh7 tu
restes un peu plus dans les fous
et la dame éventuellement
il a fait fou aussi
donc il a voulu évaluer cavalier prend
E5 donc prix il va reprendre de la tour
j'imagine
prendre de la dame il faut faire gaffe à
cavalier prend le 5 puis des quatre
c'est pas joué par Sacha c'était
peut-être une possibilité
mais ils avaient dû trouver quelque
chose contre
dame de
ok il va avoir peut-être du F4 à un
moment donné pour gagner le pion c'est
pour ça qu'il fait dames C2 il protège
tu aurais fuite il
prépare peut-être rien il protège F5
pour deux tours F6 il va ramener le tour
en F8 peut-être
et naviguer le long de des colonnes FG
qui cavaliers F1 il repart vers 3 il
veut taper la dame ou vers G3
Sacha qui réussit à jouer sur deux
rangées
leur dit qu'il y a envie de faire ces
quatre pour les noirs pour miner le pion
des trois et obtenir l'avancée
bien joué de la part de Sacha qui sent
et qui échange les dames
au bon moment attention la tour qui
rentrons à deux maintenant cavaliers fin
ça va
repartir vers 3
il touche le pion peut-être que ça va
provoquer un G6 roi G6 sur les cavaliers
H4
pour D1 3G7 est-ce qu'il a un D4 qui
arrive probablement
[Musique]
il échange une paire de tour avec les
Noirs ça a l'air d'être bien joué
ça va échanger une fois et faire tour à
deux probablement
voilà Sacha qui est encore mis en
difficulté quand même
dors bien c'est le setup défensif qui
choisit
il va chasser la tour avec cavalier C1
c'est bien joué
mais les noirs qui continuent à leur
pression avec l'espace les pièces
s'échangent mais l'espace sur les
chéquiers fait mal à greatchouk
peut-être qu'il va je pensais qu'il y a
peut-être reparti avec cavalier B6
dans la bonne nouvelle pour les blancs
c'est que les Noirs ont du mal à
provoquer une faiblesse
dingue qui se met peut-être un peu à
cogiter pour lui nul c'est un bon
résultat
salut redonnerait les blancs
il va faire nul
il prend pas de risque digne il prend
pas de risque avec les Noirs quand il
peut solder par la nuit il le fait
allez ça rejoue
et il veut retourner sur sa catalane et
essayer d'obtenir ces trois points
d'écart à la qui pourrait
lui offrir un premier matelas vraiment
confortable
il se casse pas la tête non
ne se casse pas la tête et il a bien
raison
il joue le plus tranquillement et le
plat plus facilement possible et Sacha
là qui est encore changé de setup qui
joue ce que je joue habituellement
contre cette ouverture et là c'est Dame
des trois dames
et ça c'est un peu chiant pour les noirs
pour en avoir joué des centaines c'est
un peu relou
c'est un peu chiant allez on va espérer
pour ça qu'il réussisse à tenir
il faut cette cavaliers c'est trois rock
et ça a joué pour 4 ici avec les Blancs
exactement ces choses faites
et c'est réellement tout de suite
pénible
ça va ramener les tours au centre faire
cavalier H4 jouer pour F4
nouvelle fois les blancs une position
confortable
on va voir si Sacha réussit à
à contenir cette avancée blanche au
centre
ou pas bon en tout cas H3 c'est un bon
coup
cavalière H4 ouais toujours très pénible
il veut venir s'emparer du Fou
mais après faire cette avant salle est
le roi d'ailleurs il veut peut-être même
commencer par F4
il prend une fois
il peut même jouer des 4 5 d'ailleurs
ça c'est hyper relou
c'est ce qui fait
il est facile digne
il est très facile
il est réellement en train de faire
l'écart dans le match
trop dominant avec les pièces blanches
Sacha qui est un joueur technique mais
là il est vraiment mis au supplice
bref
alors peut-être que ça laisse une chance
montrer par l'ordi qui avaient les
prendre 5 et des 4 ou c'est 5 ouais
évidemment sur cavalier prend le 3 pions
prend on aurait l'impression de détruire
la structure blanche mais le problème
c'est qu'on ouvre encore cette colonne F
ur peut-être là que le fou qui va
revenir en G2
ouais c'est vraiment vraiment dur
la fougée de semble fort
trois points d'écart à la vue de du
scénario du match ça va commencer à
faire beaucoup
à moins d'un changement de dynamique en
belette
il veut profiter pour pour se mettre sur
des 4 avec tempo
[Musique]
il s'est fait surprendre ici Ding
cavalier F4 dam G4 il tape il tape sur
le feu 3 et le pion G3
attention
attention là l'ordi qui s'affolent il
faut prendre H4 peut-être possible
GH
si on prend des quatre on reprend des 4
cavaliers prend le 5
attendez
menacera cavalier F3 à la sortie ou là
oui c'est hyper fort
c'est raté par Sacha c'était hyper dur à
voir mais
mais c'était hyper fort s'il avait vu ça
aurait été hyper fort
du coup il a fait tour C8 6 il continue
à avoir du jeu ici
il peut juste prendre et sur dame prend
et changer et mettre le fond en F6 ouais
ça c'est le plus simple puis on prend
d'un projet 6 à me prendre G6 qui est
éprangé 6 fois F6 et on tape allez Sacha
c'est une partie qui peut soit couler
Sacha trois points d'écart ça va être
très difficile soit lui lui redonner du
baume au coeur
si Sacha peut l'emporter avec les Noirs
ça peut complètement le remettre dedans
il a pas pris F7 il voulait pas se
mettre dans le vis-à-vis de la tour dans
certaines variantes à mon avis il fait
cavalier 3 maintenant il tape la dame
15 secondes pour Sacha 28 pour pour Ding
il prend F1 sur échec c'est quoi le
matos
c'est plutôt positif pour Sacha mais la
cavalier H3 d'après l'ordi et
indéfendable pour les Noirs ça menacera
cavalier G5 il est obligé de refaire un
fouet 7 quand il fait dame prend H4 mais
maintenant c'est tout rachat roi G2 et
regardez le schéma de maths
extraordinaire ah c'est pas de bol pour
Sacha
il peut pas empêcher le masser il s'en
rend compte d'un meca dame Pro 4 et tour
H1
cavalier j'ai 5 et 3 mais tour H1 est
fort et sur rois H6 c'est fou 3G5
cavaliers F4 maths
difficile Dinky on rigole
quasiment gêné de cette victoire et là
c'est le 69 pour greachuk
il est donc dur
il est dans le dur Sacha
Dink a réussi à fermer l'Espagnol qui a
continué à
mettre la pression avec
les pièces blanches et maintenant c'est
Sacha qui essaie de jouer un genre de
catalan
ah il est complètement au fond
il est complètement au fond trois points
d'écart on peut pas dire contre le cours
du jeu on a senti un à chaque fois
c'était dingue qui avait un peu plus de
victoire dans son règne
mais là c'est devenu compliqué
là c'est devenu compliqué quasiment au
pied du mur
même pas quasiment il est au pied du mur
dans la position sont complexes il peut
y avoir des G5 qui partent avec le
cavalier enfermé mais d'un autre côté
ouais c'est exactement ça
mais d'un autre côté
la position est très complexe
comme égal
à me demander parce qu'il y a exactement
sur pion prend H4 on peut regarder
ensemble par curiosité pure il fait
fouger 5 ok ça c'est la ligne de l'ordi
donc sur dam point il veut dame prend
ses 8 il tape là et là
et sur F6 vous prend H4 rock F3 il
évalue ça comme pas clair
ouais c'est des positions qui sont très
compliquées il a joué H3 e ça va
s'échanger ici
alors H3 c'était logique parce qu'en
réalité
si le cavalier parents F6 il a foutran
G5 et si le cavalier part en H6 c'est un
clouage
mais bon je voulais vous montrer la
variante d'ordi parce que je la trouvais
assez
extraordinaire
alors là de nouveau on est dans un truc
d'une complexité monstre mais le
problème c'est que on le voit Sacha qui
fait plus la différence avec les Blancs
maintenant avec les Blancs il obtient
des positions
à triple tranchant
ça c'est un réel souci
il va réussir à mettre le fond F4 et le
pione3 quand même à stabiliser
allez faut gagner celle-là pour se faire
rêver
il y a une nouvelle stratégie de
chercher le chaos partout en quelques
sortes il essaie de
de rendre les positions compliquées mais
c'est aussi parce que Dingle a réussi à
régler ses problèmes dans l'espagnol à
force
a-t-il un peu plus de chance la surface
de belote j'en sais rien mais faudrait
pas qu'il démarre avec trois ou quatre
points d'écart ce serait trop
la dingue a du mal à faire son choix
parce que les
les blancs sur case noir sont très
solides
il bloque beaucoup le jeu adverse
il va y avoir deux trois il faut ranger
5 il va juste ignorer
c'est pas grave pour
pour
qui va prendre il réglera le problème de
son roi dans un deuxième temps
MP3 il veut poser un problème sur Dame
des 7 tu auras plus de problèmes en G5
il veut essayer de ne pas perdre ce pion
après il est de toute façon condamné il
y aura des tours G8 il faut ranger 5 par
la suite
il veut peut-être se donner des
cavaliers E4 dessin ou prend le 4 des 5
ici
c'est très difficile à calculer il fait
tout Racer
DIN qui va devoir de toute façon jouer
pour tour G8 foutranger 5 mais attention
il peut y avoir des prises en E4 plutôt
puis des cinq il joue pour cavalier à 4
que se passe-t-il sur cavalier à 5 ici
la dame peut-être pas rester au contact
du cheval
oh mais c'est encore une nouvelle fois
ultra complexe parce qu'il y a de la
casse C7 peut-être en fin de variante
non il a fait tour projet 5 de l'autre
côté
la partie est dingue
il veut récupérer toutes les cases
noires fous prends fou prends
et cavaler ses cinq dames des 6 ou dames
C7 essayer de récupérer toutes les cases
noires côté d'ingly Rennes
en plus il gagnera un temps sur la tour
et sur cavalier C5 il veut tout Français
5 et on n'a pas foutranger 5 à cause
d'une prise en D4 qu'est-ce que c'est
bien joué de la part de Ding
ouais
il joue très très vite très très bien
très très fort
Hermé le fou en C8
dans ce match
quel niveau quel niveau mesdames et
messieurs
ah ouais elle est partie sont toutes
serrées mais alors qu'est-ce que ça
s'envoie à côté chinois il va faire FC
il va tout blinder
et sur dame prend des seins qui veut
tout prendre
attention il y a du Fou prend 14 rangés
3 il a pris le 4 rois F8 il a voulu
éviter peut-être des cavaliers des 6
c'est bien joué la tour qui vient en eux
envisager vous prend des quatre il y a
pas de découverte roi et fin ça a décalé
fou prendre à me cinq il y a pas de Dan
D8 il va partir avec le roi il y a plus
d'échecs avec la dame c'est assez
incroyable encore quel tour
d'équilibriste de Ding
qui est en train de faire la DIV dans ce
match vous aussi
il tapant à deux tours D8 rang touche la
8e cavalier des 6 il essaie d'installer
un réseau tour G4 il se redonne la case
G6 pour le roi qu'est-ce que c'est bien
joué il y a pas de tour G8 à la fin
c'est couvert le roi qui repart en F7 il
va peut-être jouer un fou B1 non il a
fait tomber 4 il défend il attaque
allez il y a un pion de plus simplement
pour Ding ça doit être nul mais là
encore c'est Ding qui domine avec les
pièces noires
c'est lui qui peut gagner c'est que lui
qui peut gagner d'ailleurs
il va pas y arriver mais si quelqu'un
gagner cette partie c'était digne
c'est dingue
c'est complètement dingue
non ça va refaire nul mais on garde ces
trois points d'écart et digne qui va
reprendre les pièces blanches une
nouvelle fois
et qui va remettre en danger Alexander
c'est ça le problème
c'est que Sacha réussit plus à mettre la
pression avec les Blancs
et la Ding a une balle de 4 points
d'écart maintenant
c'est dur
qu'est-ce qui joue bien digne
il manque un tout petit peu de précision
pour réellement faire un gros écart
mais on sent que c'est lui à chaque
partie maintenant qui met l'énergie
Sacha qui tente des nouveaux systèmes
qui essaient de déstabiliser son
adversaire mais qui n'y arrive pas
vraiment
mais il est tombé sur vraiment très très
costaud c'est
assez impressionnant
il faut en mental de fou côté Sacha
franchement il se débrouille très bien
par rapport au niveau
montrer par
par Ding mais bon
il peut pas il est juste un peu moins
fort on le voit il joue un peu moins
vite il est un tout petit peu
suppression dans toutes les parties et
Ding il est en plus il perd solide
il prend pas vraiment de risque il est
très méthodique
belette
ça j'ai pas par contre
ça j'ai pas la ref
meilleur joueur parmi les pères de
famille ouais c'est ça peut-être qu'il
fasse un championnat du monde de père de
famille
tiens c'est marrant j'étais en train de
regarder jusque ce que disait un peu les
autres joueurs sur le match on a Fabiano
qui gris Chuck bin sefering diopening
Grace c'est exactement même analyse que
moi à côté Fabiano
il s'est mis à souffrir maintenant
surtout avec les noirs avec les Blancs
il fait plus les quarts
en tout cas c'est un très très beau
match
ils ont fait un Bullet hier sur litchi
et qui a gagné du coup
a gagné
il est fort à l'IRESA
un tournoi sur leur site de NFC ouais
c'était pas un match
complexe
complexe complexe
il va faire fouger un fou des deux
allez là Sacha peut-être une bonne
position
c'est peut-être l'occasion
c'est très compliqué
pour Ding là parce qu'il va y avoir fout
des quatre et cavaliers de c'est
difficile là il y a problème de case
noire pour Ding
je suis en train de regarder la position
et de me demander comment jouer avec les
Blancs c'est dur hein parce que sur foue
F3 il y a du cavalier 3 qui arrive il y
a du foot des quatre aussi qui peut
tomber
il y a des H6 qui peuvent exister dans
certains monde
oh là là alors dis montrer un coup qui
gagne pour les noirs très difficiles à
voir mais ces cavaliers D3 il y a pas
d'emprunt à cause de cavalier F2
trouvable après un
et du coup après il y aura cavalier F2
et foodéca probablement qui vont tomber
si la cavalier des trois il peut un peu
se relancer dans le match revenir à deux
points Sacha
il est important ce coût et il a allez
il faut qu'il a terminé et quelque part
il sera récompensé de son sauvetage dans
la partie précédente
et ouais parce que ça peut enchaîner
avec du cavalier F24 après ou même dame
B6
ça peut arriver fort
allez il faut qu'il ait là
il faut qu'il réussisse à la terminer
celle-là parce qu'elle est pas terminée
encore
allez il doit pas y avoir faux 3 à cause
de caille prend des quatre qui est
proche de roi F1
cavalier G4 menaces G1 ça rentre de
partout là
il va peut-être être obligé de faire
cavalier H3 avec les Blancs
attention il y a le cavalier H2 qui a
pas de casse de sortie allez là c'est
soit Sacha la gagne il y a une chance
soit à mon avis le match est plié quasi
s'il peut pas gagner ce genre de
position avantage autant avec
avec tout ce qui s'ensuit ça va être
difficile
allez cavaliers 5 il va falloir décaler
la dame il n'y a pas de maths direct
qu'elle défonce de Ding une nouvelle
fois dame c'est 5 probablement pour un
peu tout couvrir allez Sacha il faut
jouer un coup là il se met mal aussi
plus très second pour Sacha
cavalier c'est 7 tours c'est 8 tours B8
cavaliers
c'était une fourchette monsieur liren
cavalier aussi Damas
ça va échanger c'est dur il y a pas de
pas complètement de gain encore et il va
prendre à deux il y a pas de menace pour
les blancs et il va s'imposer Sacha
allez il revient heureusement Ding a
raté cavalier assis s'il s'en est rendu
compte juste après Dame des quatre
dégoûté digne allez Sacha qui revient
qui réussit à gagner une partie et ce
sera la dernière de cette cadence allez
il faut qu'il recolle là
ça a su et c'est vraiment
à la sueur du front qui revient et Ding
qui envoie une dragosine
Sacha qui hésite un petit peu sur la
variante à jouer peut-être un coup de
fil à Cornetto
en tout cas
très beau match et Sacha la qui a réussi
à nous à se remettre dedans et à nous
remettre dedans
au moment où on le pensait terminer il a
réussi à sortir sa meilleure partie du
match
un peu de réussite sur le cavalier A6
raté mais bon qu'est-ce que vous voulez
quand il reste plus que cette huit
secondes sur la pendule c'est difficile
de trouver les fourchettes parce qu'on
est en
quasiment en prémouv à chaque coup
pour ces 8 on va faire rock
alors que c'est le chronomètre qui nous
affiche
une fin de section
c'est la dernière partie là c'est la
dernière dans cette cadence
le foie F5 FG 6
et peut-être un coup de C4 qui peut
venir faire exploser la position
la position encore une fois très
compliqué c'est position dragonine ou
les Noirs poussent devant leur propre
roi
pour venir s'en prendre au roi adverse
mais aussi au fou de case noir
vous c'est 4 il se met dans le vis-à-vis
ici il va peut-être échanger mais tu ne
tourne bien
attention il y aura aussi des cavaliers
c3o il y aura qui est étranger 3 et vous
prend bien attention
à trois c'est pas mal joué sur dame pro
il veut plus on prend
chasser ce cavalier de cette belle case
et s'ouvrir la tour
ça joue très très bien la des deux côtés
[Musique]
peut-être il faut jouer à 5 avec les
noirs pour
pour H4 mais bon il y aura fou 5
pas évident à jouer avec les noirs
Sacha qui réalise un énorme match
plus qu'une 30 pour Dingle
difficile de jouer un coup avec les
Noirs en fait la position paraît pas si
mal mais c'est dur de bouger plus qu'une
je t'aurais fd8 c'est un coup assez
logique en réalité
de développement
peut-être mettre la tour en des Uno
juste
pour créer un vis-à-vis de demander au
noir quel est leur coût utile
il échange cavalier à 4
il menace peut-être cavaliers EC3 touche
le fou avec des idées têtes de tout
reprendre des cartes qu'elle va lui O2
qui est poncé un pour tout liquider
doit peut-être mettre un coup de tour E1
et fou F1
qui donne pas super envie bien joué là
de la part de Ding
on voit Sacha qui est déçu là
qui a fait une petite mimique
[Musique]
dur en fait ce cavalier a C3 est
imparable
regardez le visage de Sacha là
ça fait de la grimace il arrive pas il
trouve pas le cookie veut
plus de 46 secondes
ouais il bloque
ce serait vraiment très bien joué là
parce qu'il a du mal
c'est très dur il a perdu le fil
tellement dur de jouer aux échecs quand
c'est comme ça
il a plus rien qui marche à regarder le
petit sourire de Ding
il va faire deux fois c'est bien joué
attention quand même à cavalier des deux
ici encore
mais bon c'est peut-être pas très grave
il y a peut-être du Fou prend B7 même
d'ailleurs
il y a peut-être même du foot en B7 donc
ça va
partie importante
et là c'est soit Ding reprend trois
points d'avance
et c'est
katasha revient à un point et ça remet
vraiment
quasiment le match
au point de départ ou une nulle et digne
garde quand même un avantage confortable
de points ce sera beaucoup
vu à quel point tout est serré mais tout
sera encore possible
quel est on reprend des quatre il veut
sur pion prend cavalier de Tours
français 1
qui a lieu deux rois F2 tour des deux
ah peut-être il peut faire deux
o il y a peut-être un problème pour Ding
ça va être une cale de plus
ça va être une cale de plus il va
pouvoir les prendre à 7
Sacha mais il a plus que deux secondes
c'est chaud
c'est calme de plus mais plus de temps
digne qui va chercher une magouille avec
le cavalier
non il abandonne incroyable de faire
plein de joueurs chinois
incroyable oh c'est pas du Naka
bon après il était complètement
foutu mais quand même
ouais c'est beaucoup trop fair-play oui
bon bah ça va perdre contre Naka en fait
il a absolument aucune chance oui bon
c'est juste que ça sert même à rien de
se présenter contre le joueur américain
trop gentil trop respectueux d'inglyrène
oui bon c'est pas une enflure c'est très
très grave
pas assez [ __ ] d'inglyrène
c'est beaucoup trop gentil en fait c'est
pas possible d'être comme ça
ah bah il faut qu'il muscle son jeu là
oh bah oui non mais là c'est trop il
mérite de perdre ce match en fait
non après si fait contre Sacha et pas
contre Naka alors là oui là je dis oui
mais ok si contre n'a qu'à tu fais ça
c'est même c'est ne viens juste pas en
fait
contre na Kate et enfin ok là c'est
tu peux pas faire ça
en tout cas c'est la pause on voit
dingue qui se promène un peu chez lui
donne l'impression d'être dans une
chambre d'hôtel
ah il est trop gentil pour être numéro
unding trop respectueux trop gentil trop
bien élevé
tant de défauts chez ce joueur
il fait le ménage ouais c'est ça en fait
il fait complètement le ménage entre les
parties
ouais c'est trop en fait
non c'est trop tu peux pas
il aurait pu jouer quelques coups quand
même
après il était vraiment foutu et il
aurait probablement perdu mais
par principe c'est plus ça
c'est beau le faire play je sais pas à
quoi ça sert d'être fair-play pourquoi
te faire play en fait
je suis pas sûr que ce soit très utile
pas sûr que ce soit très utile
on aurait tous là ici complètement moi
j'aurais flag je sais pas si je pense
pas y arriver parce qu'avec le plus un
je pense que YouTube fini mais j'aurais
joué au moins quatre cinq coups de plus
c'est obligé en fait surtout qu'il va
jouer les bolets maintenant
à quoi ça sert d'avoir des valeurs mais
complètement
on sait pas en fait c'est de l'avantage
de Life c'est terrible
alors que la Croatie a pris les devants
de un pour
eux les Canadiens en sueur quand même
et chessbrac quasiment éliminé de la
Coupe du monde
on peut être un temps de faire moi non
plus quoi dire envie de vomir quand je
vois ça
mais la Belgique ils sont pas encore
éliminés à un détrompez-vous
en réalité
si battre la Croatie sont qualifiés
ce soir il y a Espagne Allemagne
violence urbaine à Bruxelles gîte à la
défaite contre le Maroc
ils sont comme ça les Belges ils ont
autant le seum
c'est terrible ça quand même
c'est terrible côté belge
la part des Marocains je pense c'est
je pensais
pas sur c'est en Belgique quand même à
Bruxelles frérot
j'en suis à une fouetter ça après
peut-être des Belges qui sont contents
de la victoire du Maroc ça c'est une
autre question
attention quand même
chez eux non non si l'Allemagne perd il
joue quand même leur troisième match
Hugo chasse
non il rentre pas chez eux même si tu
perds le deuxième match et que tu es
éliminé tu joues
comme nous qui jouons notre troisième
match même si on est même si on est
qualifié pardon exactement
c'est le père ce soir surtout
ah oui en plus ils sont pas éliminés
puisque si bat le Costa Rica avec
l'Espagne balle Japon ils peuvent être
qualifiés encore oui non c'est
absolument n'importe quoi en fait oui
non en fait c'est terrible
ils peuvent battre bas de Japon
Espagne gabac Costa Rica qui sont
d'ailleurs des résultats très logiques
et ils sont qualifs
Tim boycott ici
frère
moi je regarde pas non plus mais je me
tiens au courant quoi de toute façon il
y a des gens qui m'en parlent tous les
jours
allez ça part je relance le compteur
allez c'est parti pour une jolie session
de belette
et ça repart sur du web Simco hein pour
Agri truc
là ça va être un ça va être chaud là il
y a qu'un point d'écart 30 minutes à
jouer
et la dynamique des ouvertures peut
complètement changer d'ailleurs greachu
qui est un petit peu plus de points et
l'eau en belette et ce qui serait pas
favori le joueur russe pour faire
craquer
le chinois réponse dans 29 minutes et 30
secondes maintenant
dames C2 il veut récupérer le Punto
cavalier F6 est logique gritchouc là qui
prend beaucoup trop de temps sur un coup
de bolet tu peux pas prendre 17 secondes
en belette sur le huitième coup de la
partie c'est trop allez il faut
enchaîner les coups mon Sacha
des trois tu prends c'est pas grave et
rock et cavalier BD7 allez il faut il
faut bouger là bouger une pièce
Sacha qui tente trop il tente beaucoup
trop allez cavaliers à 6 c'est bien joué
quand même il perd pas du temps pour
rien il avait du cavalier beck4 rock des
trois allez un prise et on bouge il va
décaler la dame ça donne quoi cette
position c'est égalité matérielle mais
les blancs qui ont une petite main sur
la position mais ce que j'aime pas c'est
cette pendule là côté grichuk plus de 30
secondes déjà
et il se fait enchaîner il se fait
enchaîner elle devait calculer en
réalité tu reprends des Cinq puis on
prend des cinq mais faut un peu clic en
belette t'as pas le choix à être obligé
de jouer un peu au feeling un peu plus
allez c'est bien jingle lui aussi qui
prend du temps et cavalier 6 mais il y a
peut-être un dame français 4 en blanc
c'est complexe c'est complexe cavalier 7
rois suite
roi je suis de c'est le seul coup les
gars il fait quoi
pourquoi tu cliques pas
il branle quoi
déconnexion oh non il est déco ça se
joue sur une déco ce pitcher ouais c'est
extraordinaire
ouais le clic le kiff oh c'est le kiffe
des coachscom qui coûte cher ouais ça
peut se jouer là-dessus ouais Sacha qui
est dégoûté mais oui oh magnifique 3h30
de match qui se joue sur une déco et oui
mais ça on le sait zoom on m'a déjà dit
que ça pouvait ça pouvait créer ce genre
de bug quand tu as une légère déco si tu
mets plus de temps à te connecter
mais bon on n'utilise pas discorde c'est
dommage mais oui on se fait zoomède côté
gritchouk
resoum ça pompe beaucoup ouais ouais et
quand tu es déconnecté
ça ça te
met plus longtemps à se reconnecter aux
autres sites lorsque tu es en train
d'utiliser zoom
c'est pas moi qui le dis ça m'a ça m'a
été dit par par d'autres personnes et ça
a été vérifié
mais oui
on avait la caméra ouais mais la caméra
l'avait freeze mais nos mots mais
simplement lorsque tu utilises zoom et
que tu utilises quelque chose sur un
navigateur et que tu as une déco la
connexion est beaucoup plus difficile à
reprendre
mais on a enfin j'ai déjà fait des tests
c'est sûr
mais c'est qui qui utilise zoom pour
faire le match gnu-psg
enfin vous écoutez ce que je vous dis
j'ai dit c'est pour ça qu'on n'utilise
pas discord parce que ça ferait pas
bugger vous êtes cons vous faites exprès
oh bah ça va être bas non je vais noter
le pseudo pour banne sur ma chaîne oh
bah ouais j'ai du PSG je vais faire un
petit copier-coller attendez une petite
seconde
attention je note les pseudos bon je
vais prendre juste une photo avec le
téléphone pour pouvoir mettre du bandel
sur ma chaîne
attendez je prends photo pour pouvoir
bandelf
important
il y a un jusque moi non non il a dit la
justification à deux balles pour pas
dire que c'était ça alors que c'était
pas du tout vrai
c'est pas du tout vrai justement c'était
j'étais en train de dire exactement
l'inverse donc c'est très gentil mais ça
va ouais ça va dégager ça fait plaisir
on perd pas le nord ici et sachala qui
va devoir s'y remettre
on va voir on verra de toute façon il y
a une photo qui est prise de jurer
en fait
c'est pas du tout une justification à
deux balles c'est c'est vraiment il y a
vraiment un truc juste ça se ressent pas
normalement quand vous utilisez d'autres
choses
parce qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de jouer
sur un
sur un navigateur
mais ouais bon bah ça fait tourner le
match en fait c'est juste que ça ça
calme le match
ouais ben ouais
cavalier 2 ah peut-être que
attendez peut-être qu'il y a un peu de
réussite là
cavalier des trois qui a value 5
attention il a sacrifié une pièce c'est
hyper chaud il y en a partout
ça peut revenir encore pour Sacha tu
réussisses ta F2 allez il faudrait qu'il
ait un peu de bol là qui réussissent
envoyer un tour pour un F7 un petit
quelque chose
d'ink a plus beaucoup de temps et une
déco une déco à misclique il y a
peut-être tourner F7 qui va tomber une
déco à misclique
oh s'il y a une seconde de déco ça peut
faire le Punto ici
il y a pas de maths il y a plus de dames
il y a plus rien
qui peut mettre les barbeul ou ça va
faire ça va faire perpétine pleutre non
digne pas pleutre il la joue
c'est terrible damage 7 oh il avait
peut-être dame G6 qui récupérait le
Punto h
ah c'est dur maintenant c'est Sacha qui
va essuyer quelques échecs
attention
allez une muscléique un musclé qu'une
déco
allez prendre un Sacha dans H6 tu as pas
le choix
allez prends le pot de temps
et peut-être damage 5 dame 5 et ce qui
est changé les dames va être bon
il y a du dame F2 dame prend B2 Sacha
qui la retourne
le roi qui monte
dame G2 non il a raté cette Punto dame
G2 c'était contre échec le roi qui monte
allez maintenant il va falloir mettre
des échecs Sacha
faut arrêter de tergiverser le pion qui
part d'âme G6 contre échec d'un prend
prise prise et c'est j'ai 8 dames sur
échec ça va au bout c'est échec et d'en
prendre à deux Sacha qui est de retour
dans ce match
on sait pas pourquoi
non ça va notre chronomètre qui est là
le compte à rebours qui est toujours là
22 minutes 20 encore plus qu'un point
d'écart
Sacha qui a eu la réussite là
fait exprès pas du tout
et Sacha qui retourne dans cette
sur cavalier 5 avec quelque chose non là
ouais tout ça c'était horrible
tout ça a été horrible mes chers mes
chers amis
bon ça ça va complètement
il va reculer le fou il va mettre le
cavalier en 17 mais bon il y a un peu de
il y a un peu de problème avec le pion
B5 peut-être un petit retard de
développement un petit foug2 protéger
alors que le X 8 ne l'est pas pour le
moment pour le moment
il y a un petit F ou des 6 x 3
on a un tout petit peu derrière côté
Sacha pour le moment
d'ink a toujours un point d'avance dans
ce match
il va y avoir une tourelle qui va venir
en D1 peut-être
mais il y a Thor C8 encore menace pas
tour ces deux mais va peut-être le
menacer
qui est Descartes il va tout échanger oh
là là cette finale là et ce qu'elle est
dur à tenir ou pas après faut prendre
j'ai deux rois rangées de temps D8
il va faire 3 c'est ça donc tour C8
on n'a pas le temps de monter la tour il
y a match du couloir il va faire tout à
5 quand même et ça digne il est
tellement dur c'est exactement le type
de position où il te domine
ouais c'est froid qu'est-ce que c'est
bien joué
quasiment tout un tempo côté Ding mais
qu'est-ce que c'est fort
et là il fait tomber 5 et 4 et il va
gagner le pion qu'est-ce que c'est bien
joué de la part du joueur chinois ah il
y a encore tout reprend B4 cavaliers C6
grosse défense
grosse défense de Sacha qui a trouvé
comment comment sauver le Punto et là il
y a un seul coup qui donne avantage au
blanc c'est Torcé 5 il est tout reprend
fou prend et la cavalier c'est 6 ça
chasse en sort
quel défense du joueur russe et là ça va
faire nul sans sourciller
Sacha qui a toujours un point de retard
et 20 minutes de match restant
et de joueurs qui vont faire nulle part
répétition et on va retourner au charbon
allez Sacha il s'est remis là-dedans on
le sens on le sent chaud là Sacha
on le sent prêt il retourne dans
l'espagnol Ding
dans cet anti-berlinois Sacha qui a
changé cette fois-ci c'est lui un qui a
décidé de repartir dans le 4
c'est vrai qu'il était pas spécialement
bien dans la partie précédente avec les
Blancs
ça va se jouer au nerf exactement
ça va se jouer à rien
mais Sacha semble être dans une bonne
dynamique là il était mené trois points
position un peu difficile et il est
revenu
à deux points puis à un point il réussit
à maintenir cet écart là pour le moment
à rester dans le rétro malgré la déco
qu'il avait remis dans le dur
il réussit à coller pour le moment
il peut faire tourner ce match
dans les ultimes secondes
consolide pour se faire la casse C4 mais
Tim qui a réussi à joindre un petit peu
plus vite les ouvertures
Sacha qui de par sa dextérité tactique a
réussi à sauver dans la partie
précédente mais là il est un petit peu à
court de plan Sacha
plus 18 minutes dans la cadence ça va
donner encore six parties à jouer il y a
un point de retard il fait j'ai trois
pour F4
il a tanqué énormément de temps pour ça
mais F4 F5 à tempo MG2 on vient dans
cette diagonale se déclouer le pion et
essayer de mettre cavalier dessin
au leurre quelque chose de fort puis on
prend puis on prend et peut-être du
cavalier H4
ouais c'est trouver par Ding le cavalier
en plus c'est protégé et on sent une
grosse vulnée vulnérabilité du roi blanc
sur cette diagonale allez peut-être dame
j'ai trois tours géant
serrer les fesses va mais on n'a jamais
de 5 tours géant on est dans un
vis-à-vis ultra désagréable attention ça
pourrait repasser à plus de là pour pour
Ding peut-être qu'il faut faire RER
même si on n'a pas envie fait tout rein
il essaye de renforcer il y a pas fou
français pour le moment il y a dame
prend H4 enfin il y a pas
il y a mais pas si fort il va donner une
cale ouais F5 qu'est-ce que c'est bien
joué de la part de Ding qui augmente la
pression et qui va absolument tout faire
tomber digne qui fait sa loi
digne qui fait sa loi
qui reprend les deux points d'avance
là c'est de nouveau une partie très
importante pour les deux hommes à trois
points ça va devenir très compromis pour
Alexander
il se doit de tenir ici avec les pièces
noires
Dinky réussi à remettre des petits coups
d'accélérateur à chaque fois que ça
charge un tout petit peu trop Ding sort
une Master Class on va voir si réussi
à tenir ce rythme jusqu'à la fin il
reste plus très longtemps
elle est à 5 on est dans une variante
théorique là j'imagine encore
mais il joue B5 j'avais vous poser la
question si c'était possible il y a pas
vraiment de pions-pompion
donc il y a ce changement de structure
qui vient d'avoir lieu mais ouais Dink
va jouer va jouer sur la domination sur
l'espace
tout des 6 très joli coup fous prend
puis on prend il veut taper un coup sur
C6
peut-être non non tu es B2 qui a validé
deux cavaliers 5 à AB3 cavaliers c'est 5
bloquer les cas jouer contre ce four
Sacha de nouveau en difficulté retard
autant
ça ne change pas malheureusement et au 4
qu'est-ce que c'est bien joué ce 4 sur
dame prend il va y avoir duo 5
probablement et ce cavalier en H5 qui
crie famine famine famine
issue complètement il peut pas revenir
en jeu on va être obligé de faire du G6
alors il y a pas G4 encore hein parce
qu'à cavalier F4 mais il est vraiment
dans le dur il y a même des coups comme
Dame des deux là pour toucher des deux
côtés qui peut qui peut exister tour
c'est un plus que 22 secondes
avec cavalier C5 et on se fait
complètement visser et après ça va être
cavalieux en cavalier 3 mais attention
vous ne le voyez pas mais Ding qui n'a
plus que deux barres de connexion
attention
une déco qui est vite arrivé côté Ding
qui pourrait refaire tourner le match
la tête qui va aider 3 cavaliers BE4
ok j'ai 5 aussi bien joué
ouais c'est une Master Class de Ding
regardez ce fou
regardez-moi ce fou complètement fermé
alors évidemment Ding a un pion de moins
mais là il va pouvoir
tourner tourner tourner tourner tourner
il va ramener peut-être un pion et il va
ramener le cavalier en B4 je pense il
doit hésiter il va être le plus en BK
allez si tu le son de Monsieur l'Irène
ici bah il y a du cavalier C5 il y a
tout qui rentre
à trois points ça va être très difficile
ça aurait pu un peu plus se jouer sur la
déco
finalement la déco qui n'aura pas changé
grand chose
et digne qui continue à augmenter la
pression dans cette partie
16 secondes contre 10
il y a même pas de suspense là les
pièces noires sont tellement bloquées
ce qui va même se payer luxe de faire
tour à 7 tours à trois
pour éliminer ce contre jeu attention il
se met mal au temps il est il est il est
déco il est peut-être des coding
ouais est-ce que c'était une déco
cérébrale ou une déco Internet
en tout cas il y a un petit coup dessus
pour lui
il y a eu un petit coup de sueur allez
Sacha ça se joue aussi à la cause ce
match
attention tu reprends à deux
j'ai 7 jours j'ai H2 tours j'ai deux
à deux non il refait un échec le roi qui
va devoir revenir le pion qui avance
on peut pas l'accompagner ce Punto
il réussit quand même à faire une dame
mais
Ding aussi oh elle a des coquilles qui
aurait pu faire la diff
ça aurait pu mais ça fait trois points
d'écart maintenant et c'est déjà une
balle de match pour Dingler
c'est pas terrible
ça sent la fin ouais
ça sent la fin ici allez il faut réussir
à mettre à mettre le point avec les
Blancs
digne qui aura fait qui aura fait un bon
match avec les pièces blanches mais bon
il reste vous le voyez pas mais il reste
avec deux barres de connexion
ça pourrait lui jouer des tours on
espère en tout cas
ouais j'ai l'impression qu'il est alors
j'arrive pas à savoir s'il est déco par
là ça me paraît bizarre qui réfléchisse
autant de temps
c'est très très très difficile à dire
je scrute un peu sa caméra je suis très
étonné là qui reste avec un second
on peut pas on peut pas savoir c'est
juste les bars qui
c'est bizarre qui mettent autant de
temps pour jouer on va voir si tombe ou
pas ce qui joue pas des coups
exceptionnels
allez commence à jouer tempo maintenant
non non il a peut-être juste une baisse
de régime
vous B6
à attaquer
c'est peut-être la fatigue ouais ouais
il a peut-être une des commentaires mais
c'est juste comme il a
deux barres depuis tout à l'heure mais
non j'ai l'impression que sa connexion
tient bien mais juste il a eu un coup de
fatigue
c'est 4 vous B3 il se replace ou c'est
trois c'est solide pour les noirs
c'est solide dur de créer une menace
avec les blancs mais bon il y a ces 20
secondes d'avance et surtout c'est
important et moins de 10 minutes à jouer
à une partie longue comme ça si ça se
termine sur une huile il restera plus
grand chose derrière
maximum 5 4 5 parties derrière peut-être
même que 3 c'est très difficile de
jauger ça dépend combien de temps dure
les parties mais là on est sur une
partie longue une nouvelle fois
partie qui dépasse les 3 minutes qui
peuvent même arriver à 4 minutes 4
minutes 30
avec cette seconde de rajoute les
parties qui peuvent s'éterniser en terme
de coût
j'ai plus que 6 secondes chacun Sacha
qui aura pas réussi à faire parler la
différence de temps
et même si la position là est donne plus
envie côté blanc en réalité c'est solide
côté noir va voir si réussi à pousser
cette finale de fou il a les pions sur
la bonne couleur mais
pour le moment
et Sacha la s'il a gagne pas il va
faire tellement de
d'efforts et perdre tellement de temps
il va tenter de faire un il a même pas
G5 il doit repartir avec le fond des
deux peut-être
faire G5 maintenant
il va faire G6 et jouer pour fois 6
va ressemble à une position que j'ai
joué contre rallye et ça d'ailleurs avec
les pions décalés d'une case
donc il veut essayer de menacer fou H6
en moment donné pour le moment il y a
pion prend et Roy F7 mais ça peut
exister
le problème c'est qu'il veut pas tout
échanger à l'elroit
la partie là qui qui s'éternise mais le
fond à trois huit
ça là elle peut coûter cher parce que si
c'est une nul
ce sera quoi une victoire
pour le joueur chinois
Sacha qui doit vouloir ici il veut
peut-être essayer de rentrer le full
échanger et de jouer la finale de roi
peut-être qu'il aurait dû essayer de la
jouer avec le roi en 8 en face
ce qu'elle a une belle tête mais elle
doit être complètement nulle
malheureusement
ça a l'air coûte cher parce qu'elle
coûte énormément de temps dans ce match
et ça c'est juste nul
on peut pas ni venir le premier qui
vient sur la case en fait est minée ça
répondrait par roi B6 ou si les Noirs
font rabaissi sur les rois C4 ça c'est
une partie qui a duré 4 minutes 30
et maintenant un match nul pour Ding
suffirait à clôturer ce match 7 13 il
reste trois parties maximum
du moment que le compteur n'est pas à
zéro les parties la partie commence
c'est-à-dire reste 2 secondes avant le
début d'une partie la partie débute et
elle se terminera
ça veut dire que sachala 3 objets de
gagner les trois parties
pour ça qu'il a choisi
de jouer une attaque à une instinienne
nading on a vu un dans son style il est
solide un même en belette dans toutes
les cadences il construit ses matchs
il fera jamais d'énormes scores
mais il est très très difficile à battre
il joue toutes ses catalanes avec les
Blancs où il prend quasiment aucun
risque et même en bide c'est quasiment
du jeu à deux résultats ce qui est assez
impressionnant il essaye d'en placer une
encontre avec les noirs de temps en
temps s'il y arrive
même si je joue pour nul de base mais
mais il espère placer un contre avec les
noirs et tout le reste du match si le
construit petit à petit pas à pas c'est
vrai que pour le moment ça
ça montrait de ça a donné d'excellents
résultats tout comme l'an dernier
allez on va suivre cette partie il faut
que ça gagne assez vite il doit gagner
deux parties il y aurait cinq 50 pour
gagner de game
à Sacha il y a une bonne position avec
la standienne allez des quatre il faut
envoyer
de toute façon il faut gagner et vite
faut qu'il se laisse au moins trois 30
avant la prochaine
cavaliers à 4 il veut venir vers B6
Sacha qui envoie tout sur le roi
allez faut pas tergiverser il faut tout
envoyer
espérer que ça passe
mais c'est 3 minutes 30 ça c'est
important
pour la partie suivante si la moins de 3
30 il réussira pas à gagner
allez E4 F3 il faut envoyer les potos
et la position est belle la position est
magnifique il y a du F13 qui arrive
on peut même prendre à 6 d'ailleurs
il envoie tout sur le roi c'est bien
joué tour à 3 et là il peut peut-être
faire d'une pierre deux coups non Sacha
qui a décidé tout envoyer
5 tours F5 tour H5 il faut la finir
celle-là 4,40 il a encore le temps
cavalier Bessines
la tour qui vient à 4 il a réussi à la
décaler de cette troisième rangée
dommage 4 il doit pas vouloir tolérer
j'ai trop attention pour ces 7 il
réussit pas à terminer la partie Sacha
il échange il revient des quatre Damas 2
attention ce pion qui parle maintenant
you le tout pour le tout
F3 l'attaque est violente vous prend des
quatre puis on prend des deux fous
prends tu reprends F2 ça va être pris
repris attention c'est quoi le matériel
ouais il y a du matos de partout en
l'air d'un prof de menace pas de maths
c'est terrible tiens il prend des cinq
tours il menacent tours c'est un et
c'est gagné autant pour Sacha
dégoûté il sait qu'il était à deux
doigts de la gagner allez il reste 3 à
3,50 je pense on a pas le chrono
officiel mais pour Sacha pour gagner
cette partie
et s'offrir une chanson
unique dans la dernière d'égaliser
d'envoyer ce match en taille break
c'est très très chaud cette partie qui
perd sur déco où il était pas si mal à
le peut-être celle qui est décisive
zoomed mais bon là on peut pas vraiment
dire que c'est le seul problème
on se match c'est quand même digne qui
domine depuis le début et G3 allez il va
essayer de jouer pour 4 5 envoyer les
mobylettes as il va y avoir du Beko trop
à côté d'inglyrène pour échanger ce fou
qui a valu deux prises allez 4 5 bien
joué digne qui envoie ses 5 ça va jouer
pion isolé allez Sacha tourner un tour
C1 il faut y aller peut-être du foie H4
aussi pour taper sur les cases noires
tout ça c'est les coûts qu'on veut jouer
pour ces 6 c'est excellent joué aussi
tour C1 c'est encore meilleur allez le
fou qui vient H4 là taper ce cheval
il faut le taper ce vacheux car il est
décatres c'est pas mal joué aussi
allez il échange peut-être un peu trop
les pièces Ding qui va être en mode
carapace il va peut-être réussir à la
défendre celle-là quand même il reste
plus grand monde sur les chéquiers
Sacha qui a un peu tergiverser
encore une nouvelle fois le fiancéto on
sent le joueur de catalan très à l'aise
et maintenant il va falloir faire B3
cavaliers aux deux cavaliers F4 essayer
de bouffer spion des cinq à avancer
après
il va faire cavalier F4 ici
il se place probablement cavalier B6
côté noir et B3 bloque le cavalier
bloque le fou c'est un scénario possible
de partir mais ça l'a elle pourrait
durer énormément de coups c'est pas
exactement combien il reste sur le
chrono officiel mais ça peut ne pas
suffire allez B3 qui est joué à tempo
bien joué il va falloir décaler la dame
côté blanc probablement E2 et sur dame
B2 il va vouloir repartir vers B5 à 6 de
l'autre côté il peut pas se permettre
d'échanger non puis on prend
et ce qu'il a calculé quelque chose
comme
4d4 et cavaliers des 3 pour faire le
blocus mais sur 4 il y avait il y avait
C2 donc il a fait foi il a peut-être fou
des deux fous B2 cavaliers des trois et
le plan maintenant c'est royal de roi
des trois et roi français de
attention digne qui est peut-être en
difficulté il y a pas de cavalier prend
des 5 attention s'imposent amis à fou B2
et il veut quoi Ding il veut cavalier C5
et fou B2 attention on va peut-être pas
pouvoir revenir avec du cavalier des
trois maintenant
peut-être qu'il fallait jouer cavalier 3
d'abord pour Sacha
ouais c'est dur là
de fou B2
et c'est un dame imparable il est obligé
de donner la pièce
ça donne quoi cette position il y a
pièce de plus pour Ding mais il y a des
Punto pour Sacha
ah mais il y en a pas assez pour gagner
peut-être pour nul mais pas pour gagner
mais pas pour gagner Sacha là qui est en
train de s'incliner dans ce match ça a
été in black qui a la main qui a la main
mise en plus cette partie elle va durer
du temps même si Sacha venait à gagner
Sala elle dure quasiment encore une
minute à moins qu'il tombe à moins d'une
déco
une déco à mystique là il y a plus le
choix et je crois qu'on est sur la déco
peut-être non c'est 5 jouets cavaliers
F8 Sacha qui veut peut-être revenir vers
H6 mais il y aura cavalier D6 peut-être
j'ai HGH cavalier F6 cavalier E4 non il
fait cavalier h6k arrive il y a pas
vraiment de F5 il reste il reste plus de
temps
on a pas le chrono officiel comme je
vous le disais mais on a on en est
proche et en plus c'est noirs sont
gagnants c'est terrible c'est dingueren
qui va s'imposer dans un match très
serré mais là on le voit
il a la position cavalier B6 le fou qui
va revenir à moins qu'il tombe
à moins qu'il tombe il faut cliquer
Sacha il est pas loin de tomber Ding il
est pas loin de tomber
à deux doigts
allez Sacha non
il récupère 7
ouais ça joue vraiment pas la pendule
contre car oui il va pas y arriver Ding
contre Caro il va pas y arriver
ouais ça ça va faire nul
ça va pousser les puntos mais ça ça va
faire nul
j'ai 7 attendez ce que c'est vraiment
nul roi C4
roi des quatre cinq ouais c'est pas si
fait ah non il a le temps parce que
c'est incroyable ici et sur F5 un roi
prend
mais attendez roi F5 il y avait encore
du E6 ça y est cette fois-ci ça va faire
nuit de la trouver le bon setup digne
qu'est-ce que c'est bien joué
et ça va se terminer là dessus
plus de temps dans le match Dinky
s'impose de deux points très ennemis à
11,5 contre Sacha grichuk
dans un très beau match on a senti Ding
légèrement au dessus pour moi qui était
un tout petit peu plus fort et les
quarts de points qui reflète vraiment le
la physionomie du match c'est ce que ça
méritait bravo deux joueurs qui nous ont
offert un superbe spectacle et un énorme
combat
un immense bravo à eux et Ding qui peut
être fier de cette victoire
Sacha qui n'aura pas démérité et nous on
se retrouve demain 19h pour la suite du
tournoi avec mvl nepo je vous rappelle
qu'il reste encore des places
spectateurs pour
la baarena la backup pardon vous avez le
lien dans le chat je viens de le mettre
et événement entrée spectateur il reste
aussi des places joueurs que vous pouvez
retrouver il y a le lien de toute façon
sur sur mon twitter donc n'hésitez pas à
aller prendre des places parce que
demain quand on va en reparler sur le
live il en restera peut-être des plages
joueurs pour le tournoi 1 ou le tournoi
de ou les places spectateurs mais il
restera plutôt à mon avis donc n'hésitez
pas à aller faire un tour à prendre les
places que vous souhaitez et on se
retrouve demain pour la suite